Aiaia! Aiaia!
Leute, da bin ich.
Oh man, ich bin ein bisschen im Arsch heute. Aber passt, wir müssen jetzt was machen.
Procress muss gemacht werden. Wie war das? Wenn man nicht hustelt, kommt man nicht auf den Mount Everest.
Irgendwie so ging das doch.
Wir müssen was machen.
Leute, ich habe jetzt auch alles erlebt. Jetzt ist es vorbei.
Habe ich euch schon erzählt, ich hatte heute ein Vorstellungsgespräch.
Pogge.
Ich habe jetzt noch eins, demnächst.
Ach, Quatsch, doch nicht bei der Bahn, Alter. Ich bemerke mich doch nicht bei der Bahn.
Haha, doch nicht bei der Bahn.
Ja, hatte ich vor, na, ist schon, schon drei Stunden her.
Ja.
Zumindest der Interviewer hat anscheinend schon ab und zu in meinen Stream reingeguckt. Das fand ich witzig.
Das habe ich auch nicht gedacht, dass mal, dass ich mal Vorstellungsgespräch bei jemanden habe, der schon meinen Stream gesehen hat im Vorfeld.
Tja, mal gucken, an sich war es echt nicht schlecht, ich habe jetzt noch eins, und dann muss ich mich mal melden, ich habe nämlich noch eine Mail bekommen mit jemand, der auch mal wegen Job reden will, mal gucken.
Also das heute war so was mittelgroßes, kein Startup mehr, vor allem gibt es die auch schon zu lange, aber jetzt auch nipperweit und nicht so groß wie da, wo ich jetzt bin.
So ungefähr die Teamgröße von dem Team, wo ich jetzt bin, ist dort die gesamte IT, aber das muss wirklich nicht schlecht sein, ich sage euch jetzt mal wie es ist.
Gerade in so einem großen Laden, wo ich jetzt bin, ist es eigentlich fast egal, was du machst. Es hat im Prinzip keine Auswirkungen und im Zweifelsfall, wenn du was sagst, was man verbessern kann, bist du der Depp, das machen darf.
Da ist das bei uns, wo ich gerade bin, das ist übrigens auch ein Thema, was mir mega auf den Kicks geht. Also dort, wo ich aktuell arbeite, ist es so, wenn du dich beschwerst über irgendwas, oder wenn du irgendwie was sagst, was nicht gut ist, dann bist du derjenige, der das machen darf.
Deswegen sage ich jetzt wahrscheinlich auch nie wieder was dort.
Video Call, nein nicht persönlich, Video Call. Persönlich, es hat ja keinen Sinn, es ist eine reine Remote Stelle und es wäre ein bisschen merkwürdig, reine Remote Stelle und dann vor Ort, aber gut, man weiß ja nie.
Zumindest mal gucken, was sich der nächste Zeit ergibt. Wir machen jetzt erstmal eine Runde Probe-Tage und gucken uns das an.
Mal gucken, bin gespannt, aber das hat mir wirklich gut gefallen, was er erzählt hat heute.
Vor allem ist das genau das, was bei mir passt. Also Leute, ich kann mich um Monitoring-Sachen kümmern, ich kann mich um Linux-Administrationsgeschichten kümmern, um Config-Management kümmern, also genau das, was ich, Automatisierung von Servern, genau das, was ich gerne mache.
Was ist was Gutes? Dass ich darauf hinweise, dass was nicht gut ist und ich dann der Depp bin, das machen darf? Nee, das finde ich nicht gut.
Ich meine, das mag bei manchen Sachen die sinnvollste Variante sein, aber es schafft komplett falsche Anreize.
Was für ein Interesse hätte jemand noch in Zukunft, was zu sagen, wenn er weiß, er hat am Ende noch mehr Stress mit und wird im Zweifelsfall dafür auch noch angeschissen?
Das macht ja keinen Sinn. So sorgst du dafür, dass es keine Innovation mehr gibt und keiner mehr was sagt, aber das ist anscheinend das, was die Firma will, wo ich aktuell arbeite.
Leute, ich habe Zahnwehen. Ich war letzte Woche, vorletzte Woche schon beim Zahnarzt und er hat noch mal was gemacht hinten in der Ecke.
Und das war ein paar Tage jetzt gut, obwohl er hatte eigentlich überhaupt nichts gefunden. Er hat nichts gefunden. Er hat das letzte Mal auch nichts gefunden.
Was hat denn ihr gerade Bim gemacht eigentlich gerade? Habt ihr das auch gehört, Chat? Was war das? Was hat gerade, es hat gerade irgendwie so Windows Sound, so Windows Sound gemacht. Was war das?
Wo kommt das her? Wer war es von euch, Chat? Wer ist es gewesen? Gibts zu.
Erstmal PCP-Dump anschmeißen. Ich finde euch, Leute. Dann gibt es Zurückverfolgung und dann hetze ich den Microsoft Gold Support von Fiverr auf euch. Moin, Patrick.
Schon wieder. Ja, ich weiß, ihr seid ganz, ganz heftige Hacker-Mans. Ja, ich gehe dann morgen übermorgen oder so nochmal zum Zahnarzt, das ist wirklich beschissen.
Der hat nichts, der sieht nichts, er findet nichts und trotzdem tut mir hinten der Zahn weh. Also ganz merkwürdig. Vielleicht ist das auch nicht der Zahn, vielleicht ist das irgendwie das Zahnfleisch, aber merkt er auch nichts.
Ohne Mist, ich habe mir auch schon überlegt, wenn es mir weiter auf den Keks geht, dann soll ich die Zahl einfach raus machen. Also nicht, nicht, nicht raus machen, aber einfach weg.
Und dann, und dann machen wir irgendwie oben drüber was Neues und fertig ist. Ruhe. Ich meine, wer braucht, ganz ehrlich, wer hat sich überlegt Nerven in Zähne zu machen?
Das ist die sinnloseste Erfindung überhaupt. Wie kommt man überhaupt auf die Idee? Warum sollten Zähne Nerven brauchen? Total useless.
Was würdest du über eine Remote-Stelle denken, wo man den ersten Monat im Büro sein muss und danach Remote bis auf, das finde ich okay, das finde ich okay, ersten Monat im Büro sein lasse ich mir gefallen, also wenn es die Nähe irgendwie zulässt.
Wenn es jetzt was ist, wo du einen Monat ins Hotel müsstest, würde ich es mir überlegen, wobei ich das je nachdem vielleicht auch machen würde.
Bist du bei Hetzner?
Oder wie, oder was, wie meinst du das, arbeitest du bei Hetzner?
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob das demnächst, ob das demnächst zustande kommt.
Weil wir haben uns zwar jetzt schon darauf geeinigt, dass wir demnächst mal wieder Sponsor-Stream machen, aber es gibt noch nichts wirklich spruchreiches.
Weil ich muss mal in meine Mails gucken. Vielleicht erzähle ich jetzt auch Mist.
Nee, passt.
Aber finde ich interessant, dass das bei euch auf der Arbeit Thema ist, cool.
Na ja gut, also jetzt habe ich mich genug ausgelassen, sorry for best, Dankeschön für den Sub, jetzt habe ich mich genug ausgelassen über Zahnarzt und Vorstellungsgespräche und Dinger.
Jetzt muss ich noch mal kurz gucken, ob es irgendwas im Chat gab.
Weiß ich noch, wo ich noch was drauf sagen muss. Achso, ja, also das würde ich machen, warum nicht, gell? Also ich meine, ein Monat und danach immer Remote.
Der erste Monat zum Einarbeiten, das ist was, das würde ich sogar irgendwie nachvollziehen können.
Also wenn mal ein neuer Arbeitgeber sagen würde, hier guck mal, erster Monat, dass man quasi auch das Setup richtig machen kann, Notebook richtig eingerichtet, alle Berechtigungen da sind,
dass einem der Chef was zeigen kann, wann irgendwie irgendwelche Einarbeitungsworkflows machen kann, das würde ich sogar noch verstehen.
Ich meine, ich würde es nicht feiern, wenn ich einen Monat hin muss, aber ich würde es noch verstehen. Das ist okay.
Wenn die Stelle natürlich so weit weg ist, dass man dann irgendwie einen Monat im Hotel wohnen müsste, ja, dann, ja, da kann man, da kann man sich drüber stellen.
Kommt halt auf persönliche Vorlieben und Einstellungen an, aber ja, das finde ich nicht schlecht.
Und ganz ehrlich, zwei bis viermal im Jahr für irgendwelche Events hin ist okay. Es kommt natürlich auch drauf an, es ist alles nur meine persönliche Meinung, ja.
Also ich weiß, das Thema Homeoffice, streiten sich die Geister dran, aber ich kenne euch ja auch mittlerweile ein bisschen im Chat.
Ich weiß, die meisten sind da auch ziemlich pro Homeoffice und so wie ich euch kennen wollte, wahrscheinlich 24-7 daheim sein, gar nicht aus dem Keller gehen, also so wie ich.
Wobei ich sagen muss, ich bin dafür echt erstaunlich braun dieses Jahr. Das ist ganz ungewohnt.
Man muss sich mal ernsthaft vorstellen, ja, weniger Fett essen und mehr rausgehen und bewegen führt zu weniger Gewicht.
Das hätte ja niemand denken können im Vorfeld.
Diese, ich mache Abnehmen, äh, Guide, Hack-Videos auf YouTube. Ihr ahnt nicht, was als nächstes geschieht. Dieser Trick wird dein Leben verändern.
Ja, also zumindest, warum nicht? Ich finde das eine gute Sache. Du hast aber august eine neue Stelle.
Ich hoffe, die bezahlen ordentlich.
Ja, einmal die Woche fände ich auch okay. Halt vorausgesetzt, die Entfernung lässt das zu.
Also dort, ich kann euch aber kurz erzählen, dort wo ich mich heute beworben habe, oder da wo ich heute das Vorstellungsgespräch hatte, die sind so weit weg.
Noch hinter Stuttgart irgendwo habe ich geguckt. Wie gesagt, sage ich jetzt nicht genau wo und nicht wie das heißt, aber die sind so weit weg, da ist es mit mal, wir fahren ab und zu mal hin eher doof.
Ich meine für 1, 2, 3 Events im Jahr ist es okay.
Geld ist doch nicht alles, das ist richtig, aber Geld ist der primäre Grund, warum wir alle arbeiten gehen.
Es mag nicht alles sein, aber es mag ein überdurchschnittlich wichtiger Faktor sein.
Echt, wie gesagt, soll jeder machen wie er will, deswegen finde ich es gut, wenn der jeweilige Arbeitgeber einem das ein bisschen da frei halten lässt.
Wenn es Bürofläche gibt, dürfen die Leute auch reinkommen, aber wenn es Leute gibt, die gerne 4 Tage die Woche oder bei mir halt 3 Tage die Woche Homeoffice machen wollen.
Wenn die Arbeit stimmt, finde ich sollte das kein Problem sein, gerade in 2022.
Du musst mitmachen. Was passiert denn wenn du nicht mitmachst?
Kriegst du dann irgendwie Abmahnung? Hat nicht mitgemacht beim 6km Firmulauf?
Was passiert wenn du es nicht machst? Keine Lust mehr auf Bank oder einfach?
Naja, wie sage ich denn das jetzt am besten? Der Laden geht mir echt gehörig auf den Sack gerade.
Es sind mehrere Sachen, hauptsächlich beim Thema Homeoffice, dass sie da sich so rumdrücken und rum eiern.
Erst Riesenversprechungen machen, dann Salamitaktik davon wenig einhalten, dann die Planlosigkeit, was die Umsetzung von manchen Sachen angeht.
Das haben immer wieder die gleichen Leute den Spaß an der Arbeit verderben und es irgendwie keinen interessiert.
Es gibt viele Sachen, die mich aktuell dort wo ich arbeite nerven, aber hauptsächlich das Thema Homeoffice, wo sie sich wirklich nicht mit Ruhm bekleckert haben.
Mein neuer Chef, der hat glaube ich keinen Twitter.
Dementsprechend bin ich gerade dabei mich umzugucken.
Also Leute, solltet ihr irgendwo arbeiten, wo gerade DevOps-FyFat-Leute gesucht werden oder solltet ihr vielleicht selbst jemand sein, der an der Stelle sitzt, wo Leute eingestellt werden.
Und wenn ihr nicht im Chat schreiben wollt, ihr könnt euch gerne bei mir melden.
Wer braucht das Arbeitsamt, wenn er seinen Twitch-Chat hat?
Der Arbeitsamt würde ich im Leben nicht mehr hingehen.
Also wenn ihr eine coole Stelle habt, sagt Bescheid.
Am besten über die Business-Mail, die auf meinem Kanalprofil steht.
Und ich gucke auch auf jeden Fall rein.
I know, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Hast du Corona? Ohje.
Scheint aber nicht so schlimm zu sein, oder? Hoffe ich mal.
Also ich bin bis jetzt komplett an Corona vorbeigekommen.
Ich mache übrigens schon mal meine V-M an.
Ich habe meine V-M schon an.
Nein, nein, nicht Go installieren. Go habe ich schon installiert.
Erstmal ein Update machen.
Ich glaube wir müssen mal wieder updaten.
Schon eine Weile nicht mehr geupdatet.
Während das updatet, kann ich weiter labern.
Richtig, das denke ich mir auch.
Selbst wenn du den geilsten Job der Welt im Endeffekt hast.
Du musst schon irgendwie über die Runden kommen.
Ey Leute, ich habe vorhin mit irgendeiner vom Zensus.
Es gibt doch aktuell so Umfrage.
Ich musste vorhin an so einer Umfrage teilnehmen.
Und richtig ätzend.
Das meiste hatte ich schon online ausgefüllt.
Muss man noch mal alles sagen.
Telefonumfrage von denen.
Und dann kam dann irgendwann so das mit Gehalt und so.
Da habe ich halt gesagt, so viel verdiene ich.
Und dann kommt auch das und das dabei.
Und dann meint die ernsthaft zu mir.
So viel kann man mit Internet verdienen.
Mehr oder weniger wörtwörtlich.
Da musste ich erst mal erklären, ich verdiene das nicht alles mit Internet.
Also bei mir sind das ja zwei Sachen, musste ich da mal erklären.
Ich arbeite vier Tage die Woche und mache noch nebenbei was.
Und die hat bestimmt fünf Minuten lang gesucht.
Als was die meinen zweiten Job eigentlich kategorisieren soll.
Aber die hat auch einen blöden Monat erwischt.
Die hat mich gefragt, wie war denn Ihr Gesamtverdienst im Mai?
Also was auf dem Konto angekommen ist.
Und da musste ich ja halt sagen, das war halt verhältnismäßig viel.
Weil wir kriegen im Mai doppelt das Gehalt von Ostern.
Da musste ich halt sagen, es waren irgendwie, lass mal kurz überlegen.
Irgendwie 4.000.
5.600 Euro, aber es war doppelt das Gehalt Leute.
Nicht ausflippen, so viel verdiene ich normalerweise nicht.
Das war der Monat mit doppeltem Gehalt.
5.600 Euro.
So viel kann man mit Internet verdienen.
Kackel, Alter.
Wir haben auch eine ziemlich gute Kantine, aber das bringt mich auch nicht ins Büro.
Was mit Holz wäre wunderbar für mich, ja.
So jetzt müssen wir aber mal anfangen.
Weil wenn wir hier einen stillen Beobachter von Hetzner im Chat haben,
sonst geht er noch zu seiner Personalabteilung und sagt, guck mal,
der macht ja gar keine Technik-Streams.
Der labert die ganze Zeit nur mit seinem Chat, was ist das denn?
Und dann sagen die da,
und dann gibt es kein 20 Euro Startgutschein für euch mehr.
Ja, neuland.
Aber wir mieten auch viel.
Wir mieten so, dass ich...
Passt mal auf, ich sag euch mal meinen Terminkalender für morgen.
Pog, Pog, oder not Pog.
Alter, der ganze Tag, ohne Scheiß, der ganze Tag.
Wahnsinn.
Wahnsinn, Alter.
Moment, ich lese euch das mal kurz vor.
Ein paar Sachen muss ich anonymisieren.
Ich hab sogar 2x 2 Meetings am Tag, die sich mit anderen Meetings überschneiden.
Also, ich bin wahrscheinlich ungefähr um 9 Uhr da,
weil ich fahre ja morgen mal wieder zur Abwechslung nach Frankfurt.
Nicht, dass ich da Bock drauf hätte, aber ich muss.
Mindestens einen Tag muss ich das machen,
damit ich mich irgendwie rausreden kann.
Also, 9 Uhr bin ich da, geht's gleich los.
Termin, technische Dokumentation, eine Stunde.
Wir haben ja alle wahnsinnig Bock auf technische Dokumentation.
Dann geht es weiter.
Cap, Change Advisory Board.
Warum steht da noch 2011,
warum steht da noch 2021 im Titel, was auch immer nicht.
Egal.
Also, das war von 9 bis 10, technische Dokumentation.
Dann von 10.30 Uhr bis 11.30 Uhr, Change Advisory Board.
Überschneidend, überschneidend, mit dem Change Advisory Board
habe ich ein To-Do-Status-Meeting mit meinem Chef von 11 bis 12 Uhr.
Also, je nachdem, wann das Change Advisory Board fertig ist.
Dann darf ich was essen gehen.
Also, sie sind so nett, ich habe da eine halbe Stunde kann ich essen.
So, dann habe ich Daily-Besprechung.
Dann habe ich noch mal Daily-Besprechung.
Dann habe ich irgendwas zu irgendeinem VPN-Tunnel-Thema, was auch immer.
Und dann habe ich noch mal Gruppenrunde.
Also, was soll ich denn morgen machen? Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Was soll ich an so einem Tag arbeiten?
Wie stellen die sich das vor? Und dann gehe ich heim.
Wie stellen die sich das genau vor? Was soll ich an dem Tag machen?
Warum zweimal Daily?
Weil das zwei verschiedene Sachen sind.
Also, das sind... Wie soll ich das jetzt umschreiben?
Das ist mit zwei verschiedenen, das ist mit komplett verschiedenen Leuten.
Ja, Gruppenrunde ist halt die Geschichte mit Anfassen und Bällchen werfen.
Na ja, Gruppenrunde ist halt die Geschichte...
Aber was weiß ich, was hat die Führungsetage neues losgelassen?
Was gibt es da neue Sachen zu beachten?
Gibt es vielleicht irgendwelche neuen super wichtigen Projekte, von denen man was wissen muss?
Oder gibt es irgendwo Probleme oder sonst was?
Wir haben übrigens ein neues E-Mode.
Probiert mal aus, Leute.
Pepo-Toilet-Zoom 1, Pepo-Toilet-Zoom 2.
Ihr müsst die beiden E-Modes in Kombination verwenden.
Korrekt.
Beste.
Ich habe mir gedacht, ich aktualisiere mal ein bisschen E-Modes.
Ich habe gestern ein paar neue...
Vielleicht findet ihr noch mehr neue.
Ich habe ein paar neue E-Modes reingemacht.
Passt, passt.
Ich weiß, am Handy ist schwierig, ne?
Der ist...
Ach, der ist überhaupt bei der Twitch-TV drinne.
Sehr schön.
Okay, auf geht's.
Alter, geupdatet.
Wunderbar, war da ein Kernel-Update dabei.
Wenn es ein Kernel-Update dabei war,
ich muss mal kurz rebooten, ne Runde.
Und dann legen wir los.
Also, ich erzähle euch mal nebenbei,
was wir heute machen.
Und zwar folgendes.
Theoretisch müsste ich diesen Stream...
Seven-TV habe ich nicht aktiviert.
Aber es kann sein,
dass man das kleinzeitig allein aktivieren kann.
Theoretisch könnte man diesen Stream
fast schon als Homeoffice durchgehen lassen.
Oder als Arbeitszeit, die ich abrechnen kann.
Weil wir machen was,
was ich mir vorgestellt habe,
was auf der Arbeit nützlich ist.
Und zwar...
Was?
Ja, ja, Visual Studio Code machte.
Mach mal, mach mal.
Und zwar...
Ich habe euch das, glaube ich,
in einem der letzten Streams schon erzählt.
Was bei uns öfters vorkommt, ist...
dass Leute, die Wartungsarbeiten machen,
vergessen,
die jeweiligen Systeme oder Services,
an denen sie Wartungsarbeiten machen,
zu silencen im Monitoring.
Und dann bekommt unser Support...
Ich darf eigentlich nicht Support sagen,
das mögen die nicht.
Weil sie sind kein Support im eigentlichen Sinne.
Sie sind so ein 24-7-Operation-Center.
Was haben wir hier für ein Video offen?
Mein Windows-Video.
Okay.
Das sind die mit Parkhaus-Switchdown.
Korrekt.
So, und was bei uns halt oft vorkommt, ist...
Hab ich jetzt rebooted?
Ja, ja, ich hab rebooted.
So, mal kurz zur Entspannung, während ich das erkläre.
Nee, nee, hat nix mit Hausmeister zu tun.
Es geht wirklich darum,
24-7, auch Schichtbetrieb...
Wie nennt sich das?
Erstentstörung in Eskalation zu machen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das im Business Speak heißt.
Die kriegen halt die ganzen Monitoring-Meldungen,
wenn denn was kaputtgeht,
und müssen sich dann an die Leute raussuchen,
auch zweifelsfallnachts,
die sie anrufen.
Je nachdem, wie kritisch das System ist,
müssen sie sogar Leute vom Vorstand anrufen und so was.
Nee, es ist nicht wirklich First-Level-Support.
Die haben schon zum größten Teil mehr Ahnung
als der 0815 First-Level-Support.
Es ist nicht wirklich First-Level-Support.
Es ist eher so Operation Center, würde ich sagen.
Keine Ahnung, ob es da eine krasse ITIL-Definition
oder sonst was für gibt.
Keck, weh.
Ja, das nennt ja eh jeder ein bisschen anders,
aber sowas wird es wahrscheinlich sein.
Ehe gar nichts Level.
So, und zumindest ist es bei uns so,
dass viele Leute, die Wartungsarbeiten machen an Systemen und Services,
dass die vergessen, vorher dort Bescheid zu sagen
oder eben Silences, Monitoring, Maintenance einzutragen,
was dann den Nachteil hat,
dass selbst wenn die Leute das auf irgendeiner Wartungsrunde angekündigt haben,
und nehmen wir den einfachsten Fall, ja,
irgendeiner macht auf irgendeinem Linux-System von sich Kernel-Update,
das heißt, er muss rebooten.
Geht man davon aus, das ist eine Azure-VM,
stinkt normales Linux, Ubuntu drauf, muss rebooten.
Und wenn du das nicht anmeldest, dann sagt unser Monitoring,
oho, Achtung, host xy down.
Und host xy down ist, je nachdem, wie wichtig dieser Service ist,
zieht das eine ganze Reihe von Nachfragen und Sachen nach sich.
Meist ist es ja so, dass dadurch, dass Wartungsarbeiten angekündigt sind,
die Leute, die die Eskalation machen, schon wissen, dass da was läuft.
Also die können das ja meistens abfangen, aber es ist auch nicht immer ganz klar.
Deswegen, nachdem man so oft Probleme macht, habe ich mir überlegt,
wie wäre es denn, wenn wir einfach auf jedes System,
und ich meine wirklich jedes, es ist Linux, ja,
Windows würde theoretisch auch gehen, aber ich rede mal nur von Linux.
Jedes Linux-System, dass wir dort ein Tool drauf machen,
mit dem man Silencers setzen kann.
Was an sich kein Problem ist, weil wir verwenden für Alerts
Kombinationen, Prometheus, Alert-Manager und dann halt
die übliche Geschichte von Ticket-Systemen und sonst was hinten dran.
Das heißt, man müsste eigentlich nur einen Skript ausführen
auf dem jeweiligen System, das könnte man dann zum Beispiel
irgendwie sowas wie Set-Downtime oder so nennen.
Silence, I kill you.
Das wäre eine echt gute Idee.
Das könnte man vielleicht, wenn man die Silence löscht,
wobei den Gag wahrscheinlich kaum noch einer checkt, oder?
Wobei ihr checkt den Scholler, oder? Kennt noch jemand?
Ach, Achmed. Ach, Achmed.
Das ist aber auch schon 12 Jahre alt oder so.
Heutzutage, wenn du sowas sagst, kommen die Leute wahrscheinlich an
und sagen, oh Max, Racism. Er hat Achmed ausgesprochen.
Also was ich meine ist das hier.
Wer das nicht kennt, sollte sich das unbedingt angucken.
Moment, das ist nicht das Originale.
Das ist nicht das Original.
Das Original hat viel, viel schlechtere Qualität.
Das Originale ist von 2009 oder so.
Aber das ist, da gibt es auch das Weihnachts-Special von,
das Weihnachts-Special fand ich fast noch lustiger.
Aber das muss man wirklich in diese, in das Tool reinschreiben,
wenn du die Silence wieder löscht.
Doch zumindest, wenn man die Silence wieder löscht,
doch zumindest, das ist mein Plan bei der ganzen Geschichte.
Also wir machen auf jeden Server, auf jedes Linux-System,
egal welches, bei uns im Rechenzentrum, in der Cloud
oder sonst wo, überall, wo Leute sich von uns einloggen,
machen wir ein Kommando-Silentool drauf, wo du sagen kannst,
Set-Downtime und dann geht er zum Alert-Manager
und trägt dort eine Maintenance bzw. eine Silence ein.
An sich kein großartig kompliziertes Tool,
aber wunderbare Sache für, machen wir mal irgendwie so abends.
Das Original hat viel schlechter Qualität.
Klar, das Original ist von 2009 oder so.
Da erkennst du sofort am Bild.
Zumindest könnte man das dann so aufrufen,
so nachdem man auch irgendwie Set-Downtime,
Duration 10 Minuten, zum Beispiel.
Oder wenn man es einfach nur so aufruft,
dann macht es halt für eine Viertelstunde ab jetzt.
Man könnte dann verschiedene Optionen machen,
was weiß ich, man könnte eine Startzeit angeben, was weiß ich, 20.15.
Duration 15 Minuten.
Man könnte vielleicht auch noch einen Comment angeben lassen oder so was.
Das ist aber alles optional.
Ich will das so einfach wie möglich machen.
Die Leute sollen einfach nur Set-Downtime ausführen.
Ja, Reason, wir können das R nennen, tatsächlich.
Das ist gar keine schlechte Idee.
Wir nennen das Minus R, Reason.
Das ist tatsächlich nicht schlecht.
Ich wollte es erst Comment, aber Reason finde ich viel besser.
Wir können tatsächlich so ein paar Five-Hat-Sachen machen.
Zum Beispiel, dass der automatisch den Hostname ergänzt
und sich irgendwie den Marker in das Comment setzt.
Theoretisch könnte man sogar automatisch Ticketnummern verknüpfen lassen,
wenn einer die Ticketnummer angibt.
Wenn jetzt einer zum Beispiel sagt, Ticket, Kackel, 1, 2, 3, 4,
dass es das erkennt und daraus dann einen klickbaren Link macht,
dass man direkt, wenn man in den Alert-Manager reinguckt,
einen Link hat auf das Ticket zu den Wartungsarbeiten oder so was.
Kann man alles machen, müssen wir gucken.
So, als Erstes jetzt das erste Mal habe ich nämlich gesehen,
dass es eine.NET 7 neue Preview-Variante gibt.
Und zwar nicht 5.
Und wenn du irgendwas machst unten, zeigst du die aktuellen...
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Also, wir machen minus L, wir machen noch minus List hinten dran.
Weil ich will, dass die Leute, wenn sie das ausführen,
eine Maintenance oder eine Silence bekommen von jetzt für 15 Minuten.
Die sollen gar nichts großartig denken müssen.
Die sollen einfach, bevor sie was machen,
einfach immer sagen Set-Downtime, fertig.
Im Zweifelsfall, wenn sie 3 Hosts rebooten,
machen sie Cluster SSH auf 3 Hosts auf dem GameStar ein.
Besser wäre es natürlich, sie gehen in den Alert-Manager
oder rufen beim Support an und fragen,
ob sie was eingerichtet bekommen.
Aber das vergessen halt viele immer.
Und keine Option ist die beste Option in dem Fall,
weil wenn die einfach nur Set-Downtime machen müssen,
das kann man sich merken.
Sobald man an irgendwas denken muss,
denken die Leute halt wieder nicht dran.
Moment, es gibt Preview 6.
Ich denke, es gibt Preview 7 mittlerweile schon.
12. Juli? Nee, gibt es anscheinend nicht. Na gut.
.NET Install Script, gibt es das eigentlich?
Gibt es das eigentlich auch per...
Nee.
Gibt es nix.
Und wisst ihr, was gut ist?
Wir haben noch letztens, mach mal kurz Rider auf.
Oh nee, ich hoffe, ich bin noch eingeloggt.
Please, nicht wieder Passwort resetten.
Ich hab mein JetBrains-Account-Passwort nicht hier.
Okay, hat anscheinend funktioniert.
Ja, wir haben noch letztens hier so was gebaut
zum Testen von dem neuen Ahead of Time
Compilation Feature von.NET 7.
Doch, ich bin über die Toolbox glücklicherweise eingeloggt.
Und wir können unser Docker-File vom letzten Mal verwenden.
Weil ich gehe davon aus, dass ich das Programm bilden muss
auf rückwärts kompatibel bis CentOS 7.
Also CentOS 7 Release Date.
Aber es ist halt so, wir haben noch Systeme mit CentOS 7.
Also muss ich das wahrscheinlich über ein Docker-File bilden
auf einem CentOS 7. Und CentOS 7 ist dann auch das älteste System,
das ich supporte.
Leute, wir könnten es auch in Go machen.
Aber ich würde vorschlagen, wir machen mal Folgendes.
Das halte ich für eine gute Idee.
Das machen wir nicht alles heute.
Aber wir machen mal einen Vergleich.
Wir machen mal wirklich einen realistischen Vergleich.
Und zwar zwischen Setdown Time Tool
machen wir mal in.NET, machen wir mal in Go
und machen wir mal in Python.
Und dann gucken wir mal, was sich am Ende besser eignet.
Rust, Rust können wir auch mal deswegen machen.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Finde ich besser als unseren komischen Speedtest.
Hello World-Ding, den wir immer gewaltigen.
Nein, C++ nicht wirklich, Leute.
Wollt ihr wirklich einen C++ machen?
Nein, Cobalt machen wir das bestimmt nicht.
Heute machen wir es in.NET.
Easy, NC Sharp.
Wir können es auch in JavaScript Node machen.
Weil ihr es seid, Leute.
Aber dann wissen wir nämlich, was wir machen wollen
und wie es aussehen muss von Features und allem.
Und dann probieren wir das mal in anderen Programmiersprachen.
Und dann gucken wir mal.
Nicht nach der Geschwindigkeit.
Die geschwindene Power Shell.
Bash, Bash, Bash vielleicht.
Mal gucken.
Zumindest dann gucken wir mal nicht nach der Geschwindigkeit.
Plötzlich.
Wir gucken nicht nach der Ausführungsgeschwindigkeit,
weil es ist ziemlich egal für so ein Tool.
Ob das jetzt, keine Ahnung, 150 Millisekunden,
drei Millisekunden oder eine Sekunde läuft.
Ich glaube, das macht gar keinen so großen Unterschied.
Aber wir gucken mal, was in der Handhabung einfacher ist.
Also sowohl beim Entwickeln als auch letztendlich beim Deployen
auf die Systeme.
Ich kann es euch eigentlich jetzt schon sagen.
Go wird die einfachste Variante.
SQL.
Chat, was ist mit euch los?
Also ich kann euch sagen,
was die einfachste Variante zum Deployen wird
beziehungsweise auf alle Systeme draufkriegen.
Das ist Go gefolgt von Rust.
Danach sie scharp und peisen ist,
je nachdem, wie man es packagt, ein bisschen Paintschamp oder nicht.
Was versteckt sich hinter EA Bullshit?
Ah, ein E3 Bullshit, Bingo.
Von, keine Ahnung, 2018 oder so.
Ich kann euch sagen, von wann das ist.
Wartet mal.
2018, ja!
Lag ich doch gar nicht so schlecht.
Paxi scharp doch in einen Containern.
von 2018 oder so ist ich kann euch sagen von wann das ist
2018 ja lag ich doch gar nicht so schlecht
Paxi schabt doch in einen Container
nee was ist denn der Sinn davon ich will den Kommando
zahlen tool für alle Server da will ich doch nicht
da will ich doch nicht den Container laufen lassen
wir machen jetzt das was jeder gute admin machen sollte erst mal
irgendwelche sachen in bash curlen
wie das gibt es hier gar nicht ok dann dann können wir nix in
besta laden was dann laden was runter
habe ich das vielleicht schon irgendwo liegen das tot net install
net install minus C 7.0 ganz unten war es wo
nee das war für mac ok passt version 7
preview 6 das ist korrekt exzellent so und jetzt müssten wir hier
unter dot net dot net version 7.0 preview 6 haben perfekt
wunderbar so gehen wir mal hier in die ordner repos mk dir
wir brauchen einen guten einen guten projekt nahmen
na gut leute normalerweise würde ich sowas wie downtime
champ nennen oder postchamp wir nennen das postchamp
leute das projekt heißt postchamp es muss postchamp
heißen was anderes geht eigentlich gar nicht aber das
kommando zahlen tool heißt dann am ende doch trotzdem
set downtime weil niemand kann sich postchamp merken
also von den normies von den nicht twitch affinen
also von denen die nicht eingeweiht sind was twitch angeht
die checken das nicht deswegen muss das muss das set downtime
heißen was kredo dankeschön für den zapp
wasst du den auch das ascii postchamp ein keck weh also
ich glaube ich verstehe was du mir sagen willst aber das ist
schwierig zu entschlüsseln also ob ich das das ascii was man
übrigens ascii schreibt aber ok man ich weiß was du meinst
da bin ich mir noch unschlüssig ob ich das ascii postchamp
also wer das ascii postchamp nicht kennt dem zeige ich
es nochmal schnell also sieht gut aus oder müsst müsst ihr
schon zugeben guck mal also seht schon für das das ist für
das das ist terminal ist oder finde ich das ist durchaus ok
aber jetzt wo ich dich grad zappen sehe und weil ich das jedes
mal sage wenn du gesappt hast muss ich sowas sagen wie du bist
der von twitter mit dem dicken kappa stimmt glaube das habe
ich bisher bei jedem zapp von dir gesagt so unrundead dankeschön
für den zapp 15 prozent wie es gibt es gibt discount aktuell
schaut ohne audio zu ja gut dann hat es jetzt nicht gehört
was ich gesagt habe bei mir sind es 20 prozent ist das wirklich
so leute gibt es grad rabatt ich glaube ich glaube das
müssten das müssten wir mal testen ob das wirklich so ist
noch nicht noch nicht bald bald ist es soweit
sehr gut ich sehe geflächte staubsauger sind mittlerweile
schon mainstream alles klar gut auf geht's
und jetzt haben wir rider auf und öffnen das
ach ja ich habe das ich habe das wichtigste brauche ich brauche
einen alert und einen prometor ist der läuft das muss
ich jetzt schnell machen mal alles machen wir starten
machen wir zwei docker container und gut ist das ist nicht
so das großartige problem repos postcamp öffnen Trust und open
neues window auf drei pock ja wir müssen wir müssen einen
docker container machen also was haben wir noch hatten wir
nicht letztens habe ich alles gelöscht
node node exporter please
prometos neuer exporter starten wir mal ein
ach hier habe ich den kram noch noch da liegt es da noch guckt mal vom letzten mal kann mir
jemand sagen was heute das ziel ist mache ich mache ich ok oder exporter funktioniert also das
ziel heute ist folgendes falls irgendjemand der mods am start ist und bock hat daraus ein titel
für heute zu machen also wir bauen ein tool das sich auf alle linux server was wir auf der
arbeit haben deployen kann oder mit per config man natürlich ausrollen kann mit dem man mit einem
kommando nämlich sowas hier eine monitoring maintenance downtime eintragen kann weil unsere
leute entweder zu faul sind oder es immer vergessen monitoring zu deaktivieren wenn sie
wartungsarbeiten an servan machen und ergibt es immer sich rückfragen retrospektiven und
meetings warum das denn passiert ist ja im zweifelsfall ruft der eskalations die eskalation
soll noch in den forstand anweiligen ein wichtiges system gerade rebooted wurde obwohl es eigentlich
wartungsarbeiten für gibt es gibt es erwartungsarbeiten die man ankündigen muss es gibt sogar
wartungsarbeiten kalender aber im zweifelsfall vergessen sie leuten trotzdem deswegen will
ich einfach ein simples tool auf alle unsere linux server machen wo man dann machen kann
set down time und dann trägt es für diesen host im alert manager ein für 15 minuten
das ist ein guter titel ja ein guter titel mein kaunst ein guter titel und dann wenn
das ausführt trägt er einfach ab jetzt 15 minuten downtime ein oder du gibst halt die
option mit das ist ein guter titel so wir müssen mal ganz kurz ein prometheus starten
doch images habe ich noch ein ane moment das da ist der das ist der prometheus hier dem
also muss die config anpassen lokal host lokal host was ist der standard nodexporter 9901
oder sowas nodexporter standard port ok 90 90 irgendwie sowas ganzen ports kann schon
keiner merken so als machen wir da unten den nodexporter an so nodexporter hier ne 9100
ist es so und jetzt starten wir mal ein prometheus sehr gut so als collector starten jetzt muss
ich bloß noch in docker container alert manager weil ich brauche irgendwas zum testen ob das
funktioniert mit dem mit dem eintragen so noch ein alert manager container
what the hell hatten wir sowas nicht mal ich glaube ich habe nur den alert manager aufgesetzt
ist das macht man das sollte jemand planen wie man alert manager aufsetzt ich will jetzt
nicht so lange daran rum machen wenn es jetzt nicht gleich funktioniert dann machen wir
einfach ohne weiter hier global config braucht man den überhaupt oder oder kann man auch
silences direkt eintragen im prometheus das geht wahrscheinlich nur bei der alert manager
lokal host wo läuft der prometheus standard 990 was ist hier kaputt java moment warum
läuft der java achso meine idee null habe ich jetzt gar nichts dran gedacht so sollte
prometheus nicht in web interface haben sollte das nicht eigentlich web interface haben was
jetzt bin ich ein bisschen ein bisschen verwirrt die 9001 ist der ist der node exporter der
funktioniert aber normalerweise sollte
etwas falsch normalerweise kann man nicht allzu viel falsch ich wollte mich damit jetzt
eigentlich nicht aufhalten das läuft nicht im docker das läuft bei mir lokal der prometheus
der läuft gar nicht im docker aber man darf das nicht einfach so ausführen sondern man
muss das im richtigen verzeichnis installieren das ist ja beknackt naja gut ist egal also
ganz im ernst ich weiß nicht wie man alert manager setup deswegen lasse ich das jetzt
und wir bauen halt das kommando zeilen tool weil wie gesagt ich habe echt keine ahnung
aus dem steg gerade wie das funktioniert
man alert manager config alert manager ja ok vielleicht vielleicht kann ich es einfach
hier drüber reinhauen da muss ich keine kleine container keine container stellt man ja ich
könnte es wahrscheinlich über systemd starten aber dann ist die frage wie kriege ich die
ich will ja mein file da reinkriegen mal was anderes alert manager jetzt mag er nicht
alert manager ok den system system ctl ok so wo muss ich jetzt den localhost 90 93 ah
ja da ist alles easy easy aber wahrscheinlich ist halt mein wahrscheinlich sammelt hat
meine config nix nix ein über alerts bist du der aus youtube ne ne ne aber hier kommen
die silences ausprobieren easy mehr brauchen wir doch gar nicht das reicht doch das reicht
doch wir brauchen ja keinen wirklich wir brauchen nicht wirklich den prometheus da funktioniert
so haben wir diesen krempel ich bin naja also ich kenne dich aus dem chat deswegen weiß
ich dass es jebait ist du hast schon so viele chatnachrichten geschrieben ich kenne dein
da ich weiß dass du öfters da bist so jetzt gucken wir mal in die in die prometheus config
wie man dort den alert manager konfiguriert habe ich noch habe ich glaube ich noch nie
gemacht so alert manager receivers also ich positiv oder negativ in erinnerung keins
von bein ich kenne den name bloß das brauchen wir noch gar nicht man muss doch jetzt irgendwie
dem muss doch jetzt irgendwie nur den prometheus sagen dass der den benachrichtigt aber wie
gesagt wenn das nicht funktioniert ist schlimm ich gucke mir das jetzt noch zwei drei minuten
an wir haben funktionieren alert manager das ist das wichtige da kann ich gucken ob meine
silences funktionieren die ich setzen will auch keine alerting rules nutzt du demnächst
öfters schrieben für youtube videos nur wenn es passt ist das die prometheus config aha
hier alerting specify setting related to alert manager das will ich haben genau das ich meine
ich das watt archiv ich habe gestern in dem video den stream von vorgestern verwendet
so macht er jetzt was hier no alerts found ist ok gibt ja auch keine alerts aber das
ist die suche ich will new silence matcher create heckle heckle silences ok wunderbar
funktioniert alles gut alles klar so also hier müsste das dann hier müsste das dann
später später drin ist stehen so also von der idee funktioniert das folgendermaßen
das monitoring system also in dem fall der prometheus der ruft daten von dem notexporter
ab da stehen dann so sachen drin wie festplatten auslastung cpu auslastung und sowas und dann
kannst du spezielle regeln definieren und wenn halt die festplatten auslastung über
den gewissen wert ist dann schickt der prometheus in alert und der alert manager ist normalerweise
dafür da dann die alerts an der richtigen stelle zuzustellen so nach dem motto schicke
dem forst an der sms schreibe in den teams channel was rein machen jira ticket auf und
solche solche geschichten das heißt das ist das was uns interessiert und das ist das was
die leute auch hier immer vergessen auf der arbeit wir könnten jetzt alerting rules anlegen
oder so aber das ist eigentlich ziemlich egal könntest du ein plugin für den wartungskalender
machen da müsste man nicht ein script aus dem manuell sondern wenn die wartung eingetragen
ist der silence drin habe ich vorhin wartungskalender gesagt oder arbeitest du bei uns mittlerweile
weiß man es ja nicht mehr ich habe so viele leute hier von der arbeit schon teilweise
im stream im stream gehabt ich bin ich kann mir die ganzen die ganzen namen ich mag das
habe ich gesagt ok naja das könnte ich machen das bringt aber nichts weil wenn die vergessen
haben dass auf dem daily wenn die vergessen haben dass auf dem weekly wartungsarbeiten
ding anzuzeigen anzunehmen also anzukündigen dann ist auch egal ob das jetzt eingetragen
wird das muss auf jeden fall dort angekündigt werden es ist halt so die leute kündigen
es dort an vergessen aber maintenance zu setzen und umgedreht geht es nicht ich habe
mir schon oft überlegt könnte man nicht einfach aus den eingetragenen wartungsarbeiten
maintenance oder silences erzeugen aber da sind meistens die system nicht direkt drinnen
aufgeführt die man silenzen muss wir machen wir machen das wir machen das so ok ok also
basic sachen sind da alert manager api docs prometos alert manager api documentation meint
hier unten stand was api docs api api irgendein swagger open api project go swagger das muss
man ihnen ja mal lassen die haben das sieht nicht nach der richtigen sie sieht nicht nach
einer swagger doc aus ach hier ne ja was denn jetzt ach hier rendered version also die haben
es wirklich die haben es richtig gemacht also die leute die swagger wirklich swagger genannt
haben das ist absolut fife hat also wir müssen dann sowas machen wie silences post silences
to create sowas sowas müssen wir machen aber erstmal müssen wir eine komando anwendung
starten also hello world kommt raus wir verwenden dafür kein terminal ein terminal aber nicht
das terminal wir installieren uns ein komando zahlen parser und fangen an man schon 1940
müssen jetzt langsam mal ein bisschen ein bisschen was machen wo für bauste die alert
silences mach mal ausrufezeichen projekt oder ausrufezeichen heute oder als wassame ausrufezeichen
titel motz motge wie ist das passende befehl dafür das stimmt nicht ich glaube das hat
den titel hat nie jemand gesetzt irgendeiner hatte doch einen richtig guten titel vorschlag
vorhin hier titel ok dann setze ich das mal selbst ich weiß nicht ich weiß nicht wie
das geht kann man einfach so machen nein wie macht man das jetzt nightbot oder bot ich
habe keine ahnung wie das funktioniert ich mache das nie nice nice modcheck leute eine
runde modcheck sie sind am start warum ausgerechnet hier max ja ja weil ich da tabs aufmachen
kann und so meine bisschen es nimmt ein bisschen platz weg aber es hält sich doch wirklich
in grenzen hier unten also wo mussten wir hin postchamp in das jeweilige repo ok also
komando zeilen parser brauchen wir wir brauchen auf jeden fall was für web requests und haben
wir sonst noch irgendwas weiß nicht ok fangen wir mal an also geht ab übrigens bester bester
projektname nicht korona kona leider falsch geschrieben warum verwendest du nicht den
standard dort net core http kleint den könnte man für diesen einfachen fall ohne probleme
auch verwenden aber da ging mir schon oft genug auf den sack der standard http kleint
deswegen verwende ich ganz gern den hier fluchel weil mit fluchel kannst du zum beispiel solche
sachen machen hier zum beispiel www.google.de get jason async pass mir das ganze als dynamic
oder so das kannst du nicht machen mit dem normalen http kleint und was ich noch viel
schöner finde du kannst solche sachen machen wie ich use basic und sowas der standard http
kleint kann keine basic aus der kann das musst du von hand machen also du kannst also was
er meint ist der dort net hat einen recht brauchbaren standard mäßigen http kleint
für post request get request aber wenn du mit dem standard kleint wenn du damit basic
aus machen willst dann musst du sowas wie hier machen wie konfig default hettas ads
weiß ich ob der authorize authorization header gleich new authorization header value basic
und dann musst du sagen basic 64 encode da musst du selbst es ist kacke ja kann es keiner
merken aus dem kopf wie das funktioniert überschreibt flulda nicht die stringklasse
nein c sharp ist glücklicherweise nicht so blöd in der richtung wie c++ das ist eine
extension method das erkennst du auch daran dass das hier dieses wenn man es weiß erkennt
man es normalerweise erkennt man das nicht normalerweise weiß man es nicht aber man
erkennt an dem symbol wenn man es weiß das ist ein extension method also sprich du kannst
in c sharp zu jeder klasse neue metoden hinzufügen solange du nur public sachen von der klasse
verwendest also du kannst in extension methods auch nicht einfach jetzt private private sachen
hinzufügen zum beispiel ein ganz gutes beispiel ist das was wir hier gebaut haben sekunde
wandert mal open kacke würde ich meine projekte mal ordentlich nennen ja dann würde man auch
was würde man auch was verstehen new klasse so schaut mal das ist auch eine extension method
die wir gebaut haben und du kannst damit jetzt an jeder an jeder klasse kannst du jetzt dampel
dran schreiben und er versucht da draußen ordentlich sinnvolle konsolenausgabe zu machen ich meine
davon ist die konsolenausgabe relativ easy ja aber du kannst beispielsweise auch eins
aus oder du kannst beispielsweise auch nen array ausgeben kannst du zum beispiel sowas
hier sagen wie hier war list gleich new int lists 12345678910 ja wenn man das mal richtig
schreiben könnte so und dann kannst du sagen list dampen wenn du das ausführst dann wirst
du feststellen er dampt dir die liste gut lesbar raus und damp ist keine methode die
zu der liste gehört sondern die habe ich hier selbst hinzugefügt also das geht du
kannst in c sharp zu allem methoden hinzufügen wenn ich zu allem zu nur zu klassen aber du
kannst mit eigenen methoden hinzufügen was du nicht machen kannst es halt hier drinnen
jetzt in dieser extension method auf interne sachen zugreifen von dem jeweiligen objekt
das funktioniert nicht also public private und so gilt nach wie vor das stimmt leider
gibt es nur die möglichkeit die kurz war die die die gekürzte variante in in main zu
schreiben quasi nicht für alles für alles andere musst du diesen riesen boilerplate
drumherum machen ok also kommen wir mal zu der eigentlichen jetzt mal zu der eigentlichen
geschichte also wir brauchen kommando zeilen anwendung machen wir mal sowas easy so
übrigens ich mag dieses konsolen framework hier weil guckt mal wenn ich dieses programm
jetzt ausführe also mein wenn ich ein programm jetzt ausführe ich habe standardmäßig eine
helbmethode wo alles erklärt wird ja es gibt meine verbindung zum chat ist abgebrochen
chat wie kann das sein verbindung zum chat verloren wir camp sind hier los warum jetzt
bin ich wieder im chat drin so guckt der generiert automatisch hilfemethode also hilfe einträge
für die für die parameter und sagt ja auch welche parameter es gibt das ist ganz ganz
nice gemacht also wir brauchen parameter also wir brauchen einmal das mal das mal kurz
das mal kurz in uns gehen was brauchen wir denn was haben wir gesagt list start so was
in der richtung weiß ich wie man es am besten nennen duration oder time vielleicht dann
brauchen wir so was wie reason oder ich kann es nicht schreiben leute ich habe es copy paste
oder comment oder sowas brauchen wir sonst noch sowas wie clear oder delete brauchen
wir noch ich glaube ich glaube das war es oder was wird hier programmiert macht man
mal ausrufe zeichen heute da ist doch schon help brauche ich nicht guck mal macht er
doch automatisch sitzt hier unten er generiert die hilfe automatisch das ist das coole an
diesem konsolen framework das macht dir die hilfe automatisch und es macht viele sachen
automatisch die sonst von hand machen muss du musst einfach nur sagen hier es gibt jetzt
hier die es gibt das das argument keckel und wenn du jetzt minus help ausführst sagt er
dir also hier guck du kannst verwenden required keckel oder help oder version eigentlich recht
nice ok also lasst mal überlegen also wir fangen mal an mit mit einfachen sein also
brauche auf jeden fall so die duration jetzt für schmerzen also wegen dem comma so wir
brauchen sowas wie duration start wir machen das übrigens nicht alles trinks weil dann
könnte man sich das auch sparen also duration ist ein time span start ist ein date time
das kann er nämlich auch alles für dich ja kann der das kann er auch alles für dich
konvertieren und sogar sinnvolle fehlermeldung ausgeben wenn du es nicht wenn du es nicht
verwendest richtig verwendest so also duration start list und clear machen wir zum schluss
da bin ich ganz sicher string reason so es ist alles optional man muss nichts angeben
weil wenn man nichts angibt dann nimmt er für alles die fall values das ist ziemlich
pock ja das ist das also es gibt ein paar dieser frameworks aber das finde ich finde
ich nice so und ahead of time compilation brauchen wir dann noch aber das machen wir
wenn es dann funktioniert dass es schön schnell startet also dann testen wir doch mal ob das
ob das funktioniert ja duration ausgeben startzeit ausgeben reason ausgeben das heißt ich starte
das ganz jetzt übrigens stört euch mal nicht dran dass hier noch dotnet run davor steht
alles hinter den minus minus geht eins zu eins an mein programm durch als kommando zeilen
argument das ist also das hier ist das gleiche wie wenn ich später die wenn ich später
sag so also machen wir minus minus duration und wenn ich jetzt ein angebe duration ist
kecke dann sagt er mir auch gleich op option duration requires was für ein ding ok die
vieler der kommt mit der kommt mit dem null bill nicht so wirklich klar also die ausgabe
ist ziemlich pains gem damit kann ja keiner was anfangen normalerweise sollte da eigentlich
stehen fast mal auf normalerweise sollte da eigentlich stehen das ist bestimmt ein back
normalerweise sollte nämlich das stehen option duration requires timestamp value keckel cannot
be converted to timestamp value und dann könnte man auch könnte man auch dahinter schreiben
hier wie das richtige format ist ja das scheint das scheint mir back zu sein wenn du hier
nullables verwendest dass der müll da sollte ich nullable einschalten sollte nullable timespan
eigentlich sollte da nur timespan stehen ich muss mal gucken ob man irgendwie custom fehlermeldung
machen kann custom validation das klingt doch gut wahrscheinlich wollen wir sowas wie custom
validation haben vermute ich mal das können wir uns dann angucken weil das das sollte
schon eine ordentliche eine ordentliche fehlermeldung sei nicht nicht sowas hier das damit sowas
kommt sie nicht wirklich nicht wirklich klar so aber wenn du was sinnvolles eingibst ja
zum beispiel duration 10 dann sind das zehn stunden das ist vielleicht auch nicht so schön
aber wenn du sowas eingibst wie das da dann sind das zehn minuten und so sind das auch
zehn minuten was ich eigentlich ganz gut finde weil so kann man beispielsweise sagen ich
möchte für eineinhalb stunden eine downtime eintragen und wenn man keine duration setzt
dann würde ich sagen setzt es einfach setzt es einfach 15 minuten also sprich also sprich
wenn das get value or default moment gibt es gab es da nicht diese da gibt es auch irgendeine
null da gibt es auch eine neue schreibweise für duration moment das ist jetzt neu in
c sharp 9 oder so gewesen man kann jetzt glaube ich sowas hier schreiben time span from minutes
15 ja genau dass ich mich da noch dran erinnert habe also was das jetzt macht ist das checkt
ob das jetzt ob das null ist noch besser noch besser dass das ist neu du kannst sogar kannst
sagen fragezeichen fragezeichen gleich der checkt ob das null ist wenn das null ist setzt
das auf den wert ansonsten lässt das so dann testen wir noch start darf ich ich habe den
kram selbst programmiert das muss ich mir nicht freigeben lassen das wäre ja noch schöner
wenn ich irgendwelche tools die wo der komplette source code von mir selbst ist ok ja die die
konsole library ist nicht von mir wenn der komplette source code von mir wenn ich das
nicht einfach auf und so auf meinen lehnungskasten kopieren dürfte gibt es weiß ich aber aus
dem kopf nicht nehmen das muss ich zum muss ich zum glück hier nix nix machen date time
now wenn ich gesetzt dann die fall value day time now ja manche manche spinnen ganz ehrlich
man kann sich auch jeglichen fortschritt und verbesserung durch irgendwelche unsinnigen
sachen was ist das denn ne das kannst du mit dem das brauchst du nicht das kannst du mit
dem normalen cli passen parser machen ja also man kann sich den fortschritt irgendwie auch
verbauen ja ok also riesen wollen wir riesen checken ob da was drin steht ne wollen wir
eigentlich ich würde riesen gerne die fall value geben dass zumindest mal empty empty string
drin ist chat was gefällt euch besser string empty oder einfach so das ist gut wir schreiben
maintenance rein wir schreiben maintenance rein maintenance wir schreiben wir schreiben
maintenance rein postchamp irgendwo muss das hin postchamp
ne das geht an der stelle nicht weil das ist das ist ja eigentlich keine funktions def
also ich kann es jetzt sagen das geht nicht weil das hier quasi eine callback ist für
run und die fault arguments sind in dem callback nicht erlaubt ich weiß gar nicht so genau
warum wenn ich ehrlich bin wahrscheinlich weil der compiler nicht wüsste was er damit
machen soll weil es sündungsmäßig irgendwie nicht mehr deutlich wäre oder so keine ahnung
so maintenance postchamp ok also jetzt lasst mal lasst mal kurz überlegen wenn also wir
sollten auch mal kurz varianten vielleicht gekürzte schreibweisen rein machen guck
mal übrigens die automatisch generierte hilfe ist ziemlich nice ja die sagt dir gleich
wie das funktioniert reason strings starte wir sollten vielleicht noch sagen dass man
weil guckt mal ernsthaft keiner gibt duration ein und keiner gibt minus minus reason ein
die leute wollen abkürzungen haben ja also nennen wir es mal option und zwar duration
dass man einfach nur minus d machen kann minus die duration ist start minus er so was in
der richtung ja das sollte jetzt auch dementsprechend anzeigen guck da zeigt jetzt mal können wir
können minus d minus s minus er oder wir können minus minus duration minus minus start oder
minus d machen also sprich theoretisch könnte man das program jetzt folgendermaßen aufrufen
einfach ohne was dann würde er sagen duration 15 minuten start ab jetzt oder man könnte
sagen duration eine stunde das würde also tatsächlich funktionieren oder aber eine
stunde 15 minuten eine stunde 15 und und und 90 sekunden sollte eigentlich nicht funktionieren
mal gucken was er macht aber 59 sollte funktionieren ne das ist das ist nicht ein tag das ist eine
stunde der ist bloß der meinung aus irgendwelchen moment wettemin ist doch ein tag du hast recht
es ist wenn man einfach eins ist ein tag das wusste ich gar nicht total duration an den
muss ich oben drüber machen muss ich nicht total total aus tatsächlich ok ich habe
nix gesagt ich habe nix gesagt tatsächlich da muss man das vielleicht noch ein bisschen
anders vielleicht vielleicht machen wir da auch ein custom typ dass man weil ganz ehrlich
wäre es nicht deutlich sinnvoller man könnte sowas eingeben oder sowas ich meine ja warum
nicht einfach minuten genau minuten reicht doch oder ich meine niemand niemanden will
drei tage wartungsarbeiten wobei da bin ich mir bei manchen leuten ehrlich gesagt nicht
so sicher ob die das nicht ob die das nicht vielleicht doch wollen naja zumindest dass
das das das trage ich mir noch mal ein also time span custom type man könnte sowas machen
15 s 15 m und 15 h oder so oder und 15 days und sowas könnte man da müsste man irgendwie
den string selbst passen und gucken ob was hinten dran steht 15 tix genau das ist natürlich
eine äußerst meint den 15 tix ist der reboot durch du lachst jetzt das kommt bei uns wirklich
manchmal vor es gibt bei uns systeme die haben seit anfang des jahres silences eingetragen
da ist irgendwas aktiv drauf monitoring technisch was temporär abge temporär abgeschaltet
wurde und das ist halt sehr lange tempo abgeschaltet also ich habe ja ein auswertungs tool gebaut
für unser monitoring wo man gucken kann und ich glaube wir haben aktuell produktiv
ich rede hier nur von den von den produktiven life system wir haben glaube ich über 400
silenced warnings und und kritis und alles also bei uns kann man sich schon ernsthaft
fragen ob wir wie sinnvoll das monitoring teilweise ist aber gut ich meine wir haben
allein lokal 3000 server und mit den cloud kisten kommen da bestimmt noch mal eine ganz
ordentliche anzahl dabei aber wo gearbeitet wird fallen späne ich finde es bei uns ehrlich
gesagt auch nicht gut ja doch ja deswegen sind hier alle gesilenced dass wenn irgendeiner
der typen die für die das gut aussehen muss an den monitoren vorbei läuft dass dann nicht
drauf steht 400 silences die sind gesilenced dass dann keine warnings angezeigt werden
die monitoring wende bei uns sind immer super clean und weiß und keine fehler in wirklich
keine 400 silences naja im besten fall benachrichtigen ja ja benutzer name ist gut wir könnten auch
wir könnten auch noch nachfrage machen user beziehungsweise wenn reason leer man könnte
man die leute fragen ja was ist denn dein warum warum trägst du das überhaupt ein
wo arbeitest du bei einer bank in frankfurt sollst du aber was machen also wir haben den
ganzen krempel gesetzt so wunderbar jetzt muss ich mal kurz überlegen also von von
einer idee her ist das also unten drunter das kommt weg unten drunter kommt in den summary
in den summary was er was er gemacht hat da steht dann so was hingemäß drinne wie ja
downtime will start in bla bla bla und dann so was wie duration 15 minuten oder sowas
so so in der richtung kommt dann kommt dann am ende in summary motiviert mich ja finde
ich äußerst motivierend schon was mit github gemacht ja ich hatte lange zeit github github
nein ich geht ab github instans bei uns laufen vor ort die hatte ich damals sogar eingeführt
war noch bevor die leute an githubs devops continuous integration delivery und sonst
was gedacht haben haben wir da schon sachen in der richtung gemacht bis dann irgendeiner
zu mir gesagt hat max du musst die abschalten weil wir verwenden jetzt firmenübergreifend
bitbucket und seitdem haben wir uns stark zurückentwickelt wir haben keine automatischen
tests mehr weil keiner bock hat irgendwelche ja wir haben keine githubs mehr weil keiner
wirklich bock hat github github github alter githubs für bitbucket in java zu programmieren
und solche sachen ich hatte bei uns auf der arbeit ein ziemlich cooles rubyprogramm damals
gebastelt ziemlich komplex ich glaube an die 500 zeilen war das was gecheckt hat wenn jemand
was pusht für unser config management der hat das war damals noch puppet zum größten
teil falls das jemand kennt also ich hatte jemand von euch schon mit puppet was gemacht
ich persönlich finde es erträglich es gibt schöneres ansible gefällt mir besser aber
puppet ist erträglich die e3 config ist nicht 100 prozentig up to date aber ungefähr alter
100 nicht mal code examples wie reudig ist das denn ja so sieht das aus da kannst du
sagen wie du deinen server einrichten willst package schwimmen installieren und so es ist
ein bisschen was wie ansible war aber vor ansible und ich persönlich finde ansible auch
deutlich schicker ich also ich wenn ihr ganz neu seid würde ich ehrlich gesagt ansible
empfehlen ansible ist das beste dieser tools wie ich finde chef ist auch ganz cool weil
es eine ordentliche programmiersprache der puppet wir hatten wir hatten halt und haben
auch teilweise immer noch puppet hast du dir mal was für ein ding ist es ein neues emote
keeper ich kenne key pass kenne ich
haben wir auch haben wir auch haben wir auch ja kannst du machen ja ist echt bescheuert
gewesen ich weiß nicht was ob sie ist ansible ist ein konfigurations management tool da
schreibst du drauf dein server soll die und die packages haben soll die und die kommandos
der reihe nach nach einem nach einem ausführen aus für die und die user anlegen die in die
rechte setzen die und die verzeichnete anlegen dann führst du das aus und dann bringt er
deinen server in den ehemaligen zustand ach so ne direkt auf master jolo das nenne ich
mal agilität das kenne ich das kenne ich danke für die ganzen subs hier der reichser
ist am start oder der reichser der reichser hat subs gegifte dankeschön spaghetti prime
sky linestein right kill control shift keff alle was abgegriffen der rest hat gedotcht
ja gerrit kenne ich das ist ein code review tool eines der ja welldocs weiß ich auch mal
das so sagen kann aber eines der älteren code review tools die es gibt teilweise relativ
stark angesagt auch bei größeren unternehmen wie es jetzt ist aktuell weiß ich nicht ich
habe aber keine praktischen erfahrungen damit ja ich kenne das ich habe mir das auch angeguckt
aber das war mir damals overkill und seitdem sie eh zu mir gesagt hat max macht ein github
macht ein github weg wir nehmen bitbucket habe ich auch gesagt ich kümmere mich dort
um nichts mehr macht ihr halt alles selbst wir haben ein livestream gemacht wo ich die
vor allem jenkins kenne ich jenkins mag ich also ich persönlich würde immer noch für
builds wenn es ja gewisse komplexitätsgrad aufweist würde ich immer noch jenkins verwenden
gerade weil du jenkins halt super mit scripts mit scripts customisern kannst brauchst keine
jammel datei wurde dann shell kommandos reinschreibst du kannst einfach irgendwelche scripts nacheinander
ausführen also ich mag jenkins viele mögen jenkins nicht weil es ist java und es ist
alt und irgendwie nicht so agil und cloud native und hast du nicht gesehen aber ich
bin jenkins nice drone wollte ich mir auch letztens angucken machen wir vielleicht schreibe
ich mir auf machen wir vielleicht im stream wollte ich mir letztens angucken generell
die kombination in gitlab ci wollte ich mir mal angucken aber gitlab ci ist für daheim
als sehr heavy team foundation habe ich keine praktischen erfahrungen mit mein desktop ist
bock denke das wpf gut ist oder gibt es bessere alternativen wir reden hier von windows desktop
entwicklung ich bin eineinhalb stunden und das ist alles was wir geschafft haben also
es ist windows desktop entwicklung das bedeutet dass es eigentlich nur müll gibt weil microsoft
es bis heute nicht geschafft hat ein ordentliches desktop framework ein aktuelles desktop framework
raus zu raus zu bringen mit dem man alles machen kann also ursprünglich das jetzt ganz
kurz dann bauen wir wirklich weiter ich meine wir haben nur noch zwei stunden zeit also
die haben angefangen ich bleibe jetzt mal nur in der dotnet welt ja von ihren komischen
javascript ausflügen zu windows achtzeiten reden wir mal gar nicht also zuerst zuerst
gab's windows forms das war für die damalige zeit her fand ich wirklich nicht schlecht
das war ein nackiger rapper um die windows api ziemlich ziemlich war rapper um die windows
api aber war nice ja und ich finde windows forms hat auch heute noch seine daseinsberechtigung
nämlich wenn man mit windows forms keine anwendung design will sondern nur was braucht was quasi
das resizen und ja das das event loop zeug der fenster macht wenn man zum beispiel ein
video beispiel jetzt einfach nur ja man möchte beispielsweise einen video player machen sagen
wir mit ffm pack oder oder mit ffm pack die kohlen mit direkt x rein rendern dann ist
das eine super geschichte mit mit mit windows forms weil wenn aus forms ist so old school
du kriegst window handles und alles was du brauchst um da native content rein zu rendern
und windows forms selbst kümmert sich eben um fenster ums resizen und die basic events
also dafür ist windows forms heute immer noch top anwendung damit design naja wenn
man aussehen will wie von 2000 kann man das machen das nächste ist was sie rausgehauen
haben für dort net wpf wpf ist relativ modern immer noch obwohl das 2005 oder so rausgekommen
ist ist immer noch relativ modern weil microsoft damals viele coole sachen gemacht hat das
war finde ich für die damalige zeigt recht innovativ sie hatten beispielsweise zum ersten
mal so so ein art html drinnen für interface design ja du konntest du konntest two way
binding machen du konntest beispielsweise in textbox was schreiben und oben hat sich
was aktualisiert und sowas relativ modern leider ist wpf immer noch hoffnungslos veraltet
wie mittlerweile hoffnungslos veraltet es ist möglich mit wpf dass die anwendung modern
aussehen dank vieler freiwilliger arbeit von projekten auf github
wie ist das wpf ui ja das zum beispiel da kann man hübsche wpf anwendungen machen
mit aber die fühlen sich nicht modern anfinde ich man merkt halt dass es alt ist ja es gibt
auch beispielsweise keinen richtigen emoji support der gerendert wird über die aktuelle
render pipeline für den aktuellen modernen windows font renderer ich gehe mal davon aus
dass haben die hier alles selbst gemacht dort wo das angezeigt wird also wpf ist eigentlich
auch ziemlich outdated muss man sagen danach haben sie aber komplett the way verloren bei
microsoft dann haben sie angefangen mit javascript dann haben sie angefangen mit uwp dann haben
sie angefangen mit winui 2 und ab da war windows desktop entwicklung absolut kacke sie haben
es zwischenzeitlich schon nicht hinbekommen ihr erinnert euch vielleicht noch an ribbon
bars das zeug da oben das war der heiße shit in windows xp damals noch und teilweise auch
windows 7 es gab beispielsweise nie ordentliche wpf unterstützung dafür so und danach haben
sie sonst fast gemacht uwp was bis heute nix taugt wo du nicht mal einfaches screenshot
anwendung drinnen machen kannst winui 2 was dann irgendwie ein bisschen auf uwp aufgesetzt
hat winui 3 was eigentlich eine ziemlich gute neue sache ist wo sie aber nicht zu potten
kommen und nix gescheites bei rauskommt maui was eher xamarin 2.0 ist und sagt es wäre
eine cross platform ohne richtig cross platform zu sein also ganz ehrlich windows desktop entwicklung
ist kacke also wpf ist wenn du anwendungen haben möchtest die modern aussehen und die
native funktionen brauchen wahrscheinlich also sowas wie mache mal einen screenshot und
sowas oder auf windows api zugreifen willst wahrscheinlich noch das beste aber ganz im
ernst ich würde wahrscheinlich windows anwendung wohl oder übel in irgendetwas anderem machen
neuerdings gibt es noch neu gibt es noch paar andere alternativen es gibt noch avalonia
das ist nicht von microsoft entwickelt das nimmt ein bisschen die ideen von wpf allerdings
neu implementiert cross platform das finde ich relativ gut hat nicht umsonst viele sterne
finde ich nice ich weiß nicht aber vielleicht ist er einfach nur stiller zuschauer gucken
was ich hier so treibe ich dachte ich dachte für einen kurzen moment ich habe buber gezeigt
im stream und muss jetzt mein wort von heute löschen aber zum glück zum glück nicht
also avalonia ist wahrscheinlich dein bester bett was ein satz ist wahrscheinlich das beste
was du aktuell nehmen kannst für net desktop cross platform entwicklung tauri tauri ist
ja glaube ich auch das gleiche wie elektron nur dass es die native browser sachen nimmt
ja es ist halt wenn es halt nicht elektron wäre ne
ich habe gehört dass das neue java gui zeug gar nicht so schlecht sein soll es ist das
neue ist das java fx ich habe keine ahnung es kann sein dass übelsten schrott erzähle
das kenne ich nicht was ist das wales soll das soll das angelehnt sein an rails oder
ach das ist go das kenne ich nicht interessant beispiele
examples oder irgendwas docks ach so das ist ein browser das ist quasi
elektron wo bloß noch js durch go ersetzt oder wie warum nicht ok wir machen mal weiter
ich sehe schon das ist ein super simples programm aber wir kommen heute nicht nicht nicht super
ist es kein web view ok das ist interessant das book marque ich mir mal das merke ich
mir vielleicht machen wir damit was wie ist es ist es webkit ja was denn jetzt ich denke
es ist kein browser jetzt werdet euch mal ein ich webkit ist auch ein browser egal leute
wir machen jetzt weiter das wird ja heute wir kommen heute wir kommen heute zu gar nichts
also jetzt aber fokus champ also wir setzen standardwerte 15 minuten von jetzt an am ende
gibt es ein summary so wir machen auch wir machen auch farbige konsolenausgabe wir machen
auch farbische konsolenausgabe weil farbische konsolenausgabe nice aussieht achtwort genau
so wir machen nämlich jetzt hier summary wir machen jetzt wir machen jetzt hier summary
ich habe übrigens vergessen wie man das schreibt ich glaube man schreibt hier yellow irgendwie
so und dann macht man das zu und dann hat man eine gelbe ausgabe ja guck hier bam bold
muss es sein und blink blink das funktioniert das allerwichtigste feature überhaupt was
war das habt ihr es auch gehört leute auch jeder ich gebe zu der tschibet der tschibet
war schlecht der tschibet war schlecht man hat man hat gemerkt dass ich es gefakt habe
ok ich gebe zu ich habe ich habe tschibet ok ich glaube summary blinken lassen ist vielleicht
ein bisschen bisschen zu viel das guten spektakonsole kann das text center text center text kann
es text text zentrieren allein oder sowas allein wie macht man das das geht bestimmt
ich weiß bloß nicht wie das funktioniert allein text das geht bestimmt
ich weiß bloß nicht wie left allein guck mal da wie macht er das was für ein ding
ach der kann sogar banner machen das ist nice sekunde sekunde leute das muss ich jetzt
ausprobieren zack picket text summary was hat er jetzt für schmerzen oder einfach nur
right warum geht right line nicht right a line justify center und jetzt ok color yellow
so mal gucken wie das jetzt aussieht leute alter massive park jam so muss das sein wir
haben zwar noch nix an funktionalität für unsere konsolenanwendung gebaut aber unser
summary prompt ist schon mal wirklich poggers also da geht mir richtig einer ab bei wenn
ich das sehe das das programm kann nix wir haben eine stunde 45 minuten nix geschafft
aber einen guten summary prompt haben wir blinken moment moment ich bin mir nicht ganz
sicher ob wir sowas wie bolt oder so machen können wahrscheinlich nicht wahrscheinlich
können das nicht wahrscheinlich kann das nicht blinken lassen ich glaube wir können
es nicht ich glaube wir können es nicht right markup ne ich glaube das funktioniert nicht
aber wir können wir können den font ändern ja also man könnte man könnte den font hier
ja alter man könnte man könnte den font ja das egal leute man nicht übertreiben so
ist ok was ich mich frage ist muss es da für figlet installiert haben wir haben es nämlich
installiert weil damit kann man solche sachen hier machen ja ich bin mir nicht sicher ob
die das in c sharp selbst programmiert haben oder ob man ob man das installiert haben muss
ich de installiert das einfach mal und gucke ob es dann immer noch läuft ok es läuft immer
noch alles gut so wunderbar reicht so kann die leib farbverlauf wir können das ganze
leute hier für euch farbverlauf ich glaube die haben figlet in c sharp in dotnet nachgebaut
würde ich würde ich mal wenn ich mir das hier so angucke würde ich mal vermuten ja
ok samuri wunderbar kann man so viel font size ok also weiter
ok spektrum console gradient heißt auch farbverlauf oder wie heißt denn farbverlauf englisch
gradient sag ich doch kacke ne das wird nicht unterstützt leute keine farbverläufe saurei
stell euch mal vor konsole anwendung kann keine farbverläufe man könnte das selbst
machen aber wollte nicht übertreiben design ist das allerwichtigste ok also samuri gut
wir machen jetzt mal wirklich was sinnvolles hier ist der alert manager also wenn man wenn
man das ding setzt jetzt müssen wir quasi eine silence eintragen im alert manager den
haben wir hier meine augen alter meine augen was ist jetzt los was habe ich hier angeklickt
hoff warum kann er das warum kann er das nicht da bin ich jetzt bescheuert oder was
warum geht das nicht auf anderen seiten gibt es doch auch ah leute warum geht das nicht
ich wollte den battlefield mod spielen ne ne ne ne das das das funktioniert nicht das
müsste hier eigentlich an und aus gehen leute ich starte mal kurz mein browser neu ist bestimmt
verbugged oh gott firefox history restore session was ist denn das für ein schwachsinn warum
geht der dark reader hier nicht habe ich irgendwie local haust gefiltert oder so ich kann es
auch hier nicht löschen das ist für local haust ausgeschaltet oder ich kann mir das
nicht angucken da da dreh ich durch glaube habe ich habe ich hier einen dark reader und
hier ist das wusste ich brauche ich brauche das hier hat er hat er vielleicht selbst
irgendeinen color theme oder so meine augen unten auf site list ok sack
hier
haben wir das jetzt hier löschen sehr gut viel besser saved so jetzt können wir was
sinnvolles machen also wir setzen hier die optionen also sprich wir brauchen jetzt einen
post request auf die url vom alert manager slash silences probieren wir das mal kurz
von hand aus ob das funktioniert also karl local haust part 90 93 schlecht slash silences
page non faun ja wahrscheinlich weil htp davor fehlen
ist es slash silences im gui ist es im gui ist es raute weil weil kleinzeit rendering
muss vielleicht x post machen oder so alert manager api karl
was ist für eine bescheuerte api dock ok passt funst
also posten wir überhaupt ja ich mache ich mache da mal eine klasse ich was zeigt mal
her immer interessant was so alles gibt genet konformen open api specification da muss ich
da muss ich ein extra speck feil das habe ich ja hier nicht anlegen es braucht kein
jason zu schieße scharp da gibt es jede menge ich brauche einen aus swagger was sound
leckt wirklich es war doch es war davon wieder am verkacken geht eigentlich nur da leckt
nix da leckt nix aber es ist egal bevor wir da jetzt lange rum machen ich baue noch mal
eine klasse draus das geht ja nicht so als würde es jetzt irgendwie drei stunden dauern
daraus eine klasse zu bauen so also klasse silence silence prob all die matches wie muss
man das denn angeben also chat ich habe keine ahnung wo man hier irgendwas generieren kann
es haben fünf leute fünf verschiedene links gepostet wo mir nicht klar ist wer hier sich
jetzt da auf was bezieht also wenn jetzt ich meine ich habe da nichts dagegen ich generiere
das auch aber muss mir irgend einer posten wo und was davon ja dass man jason in rider
posten kann weiß ich das bringt mir hier an der stelle ja anscheinend nix oder wartet
mal das ist doch so application jason es müsste doch eigentlich funktionieren moment
konnte das nicht konnte das nicht ich erinnere dir sicher das ging wo müssen wir hin ok
swagger code gern und jetzt ich sehe hier nix wo ich irgendwas generieren kann ich soll
mich anmelden ich soll irgendwas downloaden das bringt mir nix warte mal wie ging das
denn noch mal rider jason to see scharp class das ging doch copy jason body inside the first
code and make sure that jason string is well click convert in order to start ok wie geht
das moment das ist das ist nicht rider das ist irgendeine andere crap leute die hatten
letzten so richtig coolen service ich habe vergessen wie diese seite heißt jason zu
z scharp class die war wirklich gut aber rider kann das doch eigentlich auch also ich meine
go land kanns rider kann das doch auch oder oder können die das nicht quick type war das
genau quick type i o das habe ich gesucht gut dass sie das hier reingeschrieben haben
anscheinend kann das rider wirklich nicht ich hätte gedacht das funktioniert das genau
das hatten wir das letzte mal schon richtig genau what the fuck will ihr einfach was eintragen
kann ich nicht btf kann ich alle ich will ja was eintragen wo ist das problem jetzt hat
es funktioniert alles klar ja sowas da brauchen wir das ist das ist wirklich praktisch man
kann übrigens auch sagen wie er was machen soll ja oder zum beispiel ob der auch die
sachen drumherum dass ein komplett ausführbares programm hast brauche aber keiner types just
just types so zack da sind wir wunderbar es ist nicht klasse welcome es ist klar es ist
klasse silence und es ist klasse matcher oder das passt passt eigentlich auch nicht partial
es ist komplett implementiert alles klar so jetzt können wir den post request machen
und zwar post jason wir brauchen eine silence new silence und dann zum beispiel swagger
code generation pet stores aber noch nicht nach ruby oder ist es nach was er nach was
er konvertieren soll ok wisst ihr was wir sind eh schon beim basteln swagger code gen
gibt es das gibt es das hier drinnen swagger swagger code gen out of out of date ok das
muss ich mir das reicht zu kommen ich habe jetzt kein bock ewig rumzumachen ich meine
es war super simples was wir eigentlich machen wollen schon drei stunden am rumbasten ok
also comment ist bei uns reason gibt es ja sonst nicht so id muss man dem wirklich eine
id angeben oder legt er die automatisch an wartet mal was war davon jetzt required und
was nicht id ist nicht required id macht er selbst id ist bloated id prominent aber wenn
man die später abrufen braucht man die vielleicht so dann matchers das ist wo wir hostname reinschreiben
müssen created by das ist tatsächlich ganz wisst ihr was wir machen noch wir machen
noch ein anderes argument und zwar so was dass man noch angeben kann wer das ding erstellt
hat das finde ich eigentlich ganz sinnig und standardmäßig hat es der post champ erstellt
wenn sonst keiner erstellt hat das finde ich gut so created by ends at starts at ok starts
at ist bei uns hier moment was moment warum ist das überhaupt datetime sekunde was hatten
das ding da konvertiert datetime offset war da mal der unterschied zwischen datetime und
datetime offset war datetime offset ist datetime mit mit zeitzone dabei kann man das irgendwie
konvertieren gescheit datetime die dinger sind relativ neu datetime offset from datetime
oder new einfach new und dann ein datetime rein stecken oder mal ganz davon abgesehen
das ist schon ok das muss kein datetime offset sein das ganze tu läuft mit dem mit der zeitzone
des des servers wobei ich bin echt nicht sicher bin gibt es problem muss schon mal gibt es
probleme mit utc also sprich ist das jetzt in utc oder nicht ach so value muss in value
sein weil wir haben hier was reingeschrieben wenn es null ist so ends so die silence hört
auf start plus duration jetzt ist das natürlich ein bisschen nervig wenn man immer value hinten
dran schreiben muss vielleicht soll ich das einmal ich hier oben neu anlegen
ne ne utc now ist blöd weil aus irgendwelchen gründen auf der arbeit läuft unser alert
manager in utc und du musst die zeit in utc eintragen was bescheuert das was jetzt zwei
stunden falsch ist also ich muss das ich muss ich müsste das umrechnen in utc von unserer
aktuellen zeit da muss ich was überlegen zeitstampel in utc doch ist das hier das
ist ein zeitstampel in utc datetime now also datetime ist glaube ich standardmäßig utc
du kannst auch culture setzen ach so ja das ist richtig ja ihr habt recht chat ihr habt
recht keckel ja ja ihr habt recht ich habe jetzt habe ich nicht gesehen so create silence
bei post saison matcher matcher so new
doch die eingabe ist utc ne ne ne moment die eingabe ist nicht utc ach du hast recht ja
es gibt probleme mit utc ich muss es konvertieren muss ich mir dann überlegen vielleicht erst
mal gucken dass die silence funktioniert new matcher so is name value so name hostname
value ja mein lokaler wie ging das nochmal system ok warte mal in c-sharp hostname system
machine name ne system es war irgendwie so was system info machine name irgendwas in
der richtung schaue system machine name environment machine name environment machine name was
alles kann ich mir da auch nicht mehr so reformat excellent so und jetzt müssen wir noch sagen
equals true die matcher syntax ist echt naja naja warum macht denn der da kein leerzeichen
dran macht er mit dem format leerzeichen das geht nach mein weg so und jetzt posten wir
die silence dahin und dann hoffen wir dass es funktioniert erwarten sollten wir das ganze
noch ach so das ist nicht async jetzt async run async await so vielleicht hoffe das geht
um wobei ich muss es nicht async ran so ok schauen wir mal ob der jetzt das silence anlegt
ich bin ja mal gespannt er sollte ohne jegliche option des silence von jetzt und in 15 minuten
anlegen autocomplete chat plugin das wärs leute five hat time an autocomplete was ich
aus meinem chat leute das das ist eine supergeile plugin idee für irgendwas chat auto auto complete
plugin gibst du ein chat das ist das ist richtig feifett leute in telichamp du gibst den chat
ein und der splittet einfach sich wörter raus und du kannst dann autocomplete vom chat
machen das ist doch mal was das ist richtig richtig richtig feifett high IQ so alert manager
silences hey es hat funktioniert guck mal leute hostname poggers also mein rechner hier
heißt ja hostname poggers hostname minus f lokt moment wie kann wie kann hostname und
hostname minus f was unterschiedliches ausgeben weil mein host weil mein host eintrag falsch
ist ich habe mein host eintrag verkackt guck mal ich habe ich habe wahrscheinlich mein
host eintrag verkackt aber unsere server haben hier ein host eintrag nicht verkackt das passt
ok also das hat funktioniert guck mal da macht ein eintrag startet jetzt endet in 15 minuten
created by post jam maintenance, status, status active wisst ihr was hey das mit dem created
das mit dem created ist eigentlich richtig richtig big brain wisst ihr warum jetzt kann
ich nämlich über den get request abrufen was es für silences gibt und ich suche mir
einfach alle silences raus die created by post jam sind dann habe ich alles meine silences
die die mit diesem tool gesetzt wurden wie ruft man denn wie ruft man denn die ganzen
silences ab get moment gibt es nicht irgendwie einen filter oder so ach nee matcher nee nee
nee passt schon ich muss das gar nicht filtern ich kann einfach ich kann doch einfach nach
dem matcher filtern getable silences ist dieser namen von den dinger moment ich brauche zwei
verschiedene silences models wirklich das ist ja eklig das ist ja eklig ich brauche
ernsthaft eine eine eine setable silences und eine getable silences was ist das für
eine bescheuerte ab hier es gibt zwei unterschiedliche naja gut ich mein status status status brauche
ich eigentlich nur der chat ist nicht leise der hat bloß gerade seit zwei minuten okay
jetzt ist er gerade leise aber vorher hat er gespammt wie sonst was chat ihr werdet
vermisst aber könnte wir könnten noch die das ist doch alles genau das gleiche nur da
ist der chat guck hier ja nur dass wir eigentlich noch status status brauchen ansonsten nix
das kann doch ruhig alles in die gleiche klasse rein aber die können wir übrigens
noch noch besser schreiben so weil jetzt können wir das nämlich mal abfragen so wir setzen
jetzt keine silences wir fragen die mal ab weil ich brauche jetzt spätestens beim list
muss ich das ja ausgeben was da was der was der get jason async silences und jetzt schauen
wir mal ob da was sinnvolles bei rauskommt wenn ich das abfrage was jetzt could not be
deserialized cringe warum nicht ah weil ein array zurückkommt ja das ist natürlich doof
da kommt ein array zurück ok ich mein kann ich einfach sagen list aus silences funktioniert
das das funst gut sehr schön eines eines silence collection wir können es auch ein
innumerable machen es eigentlich auch funktionieren ja nice ok und jetzt können wir das mal gucken
was silences gleich das silences first ah ne da muss ich kein print so mal gucken ob
der das jetzt auch gescheit abfragen kann weil ich will erlisten funst guck mal also
der code generator ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch ja das ist die silence die ich gesetzt habe
ich das ist die interne id von dem dem status ist active matcher ist auf hostname poggers
ach so wie kann ich denn filtern kann ich filtern überhaupt kann man den a list of
matchers aha ok moment
parameters a list of matchers a list of matchers filters silences by ähm gibt's da für ein
filter aha nach was will ich denn filtern ist doch gut ja passt status setzen wir nicht
ja ja das ist alles gut so id und so setzen wir beim creat nicht ähm wir müssen es aber
noch filtern weil wir haben viele silences sonst dauert das zu lang ne also wahrscheinlich
jetzt muss ich jetzt sowas sagen wie hier bevor ich sag get json also muss ich was sagen
with parameter oder para ne wie war das parameter set parameter set query parameter genau filter
filter und jetzt muss ich wahrscheinlich sagen hostname gleich poggers nur mal testen ob
das funktioniert äh ok
funst filter gleich post jam ich glaube das geht nicht der filtert auf die matcher das
stand das stand auch da guck da stand auch hier a list of matchers to filter und created
by ist kein matcher also im prinzip brauche ich sowas wie wahr hostname gleich environment
ne created by ist glaube ich auch kein matcher aber das können wir mal ausprobieren environment
machine name wobei ich den fqdn brauche ich brauche den fqdn mit machine name ist eh doof
c sharp hostname fqdn wahrscheinlich muss ich das mit dns machen nein alter moment c plus
plus achso ich hätte sollte vielleicht c sharp ausschreiben und ich werde übrigens
gar wieder geflashbanked get hostname return fqdn was dns get hostname ok also dns get hostname
was will ich haben hoffentlich checkt er das was kommt denn da raus poggers ne ich will
den fqdn haben ich will nicht dass poggers rauskommt das soll nicht poggers rauskommen
also wenn stack overflow das schon ich weiß nicht schlecht was weird champ was was was
ist das so kompliziert ip global properties get ip
ist das ist das wirklich euer euer ernst noch mal ja das funktioniert ja mein host eintrag
ist halt kacke also das funktioniert dns get host entry localhost hostname jetzt mal das
kann doch nicht euer ernst sein microsoft please da muss es doch moment moment da muss
es was besseres geben das ist doch das ist doch von 2016 das ist wenigstens halbwegs
ok das ist ja wirklich naja naja ich ich weiß ja nicht also microsoft da hättet ihr durchaus
eine schönere api bauen können für go f ja ich kann ja halt kein go package verwenden
übrigens jetzt ach nee mist ha jetzt wollte ich euch grad was cooles zeigen aber es funktioniert
nicht weil mal das static ist die könnte die kann man nicht die kann man nicht erweitern
oder kann man mittlerweile extension methods machen für statische klassen ich glaube das
funktioniert nicht top top das geht nicht ne ne das geht nicht als früher ging es auf
jeden fall nicht und vielleicht vielleicht dachte die haben was getan aber nie geht nicht
na gut dann lassen wir es halt so meinetwegen ja dns get hostname string empty hostname
bäh ok also da haben wir den hostname der kommt dann auch bei der silence rein hostname
matcher hostname value es ist schon ein bisschen paint's jam oder müsst ihr zugeben also schon
ein bisschen bisschen eklig so also das abfragen funktioniert auch wunderbar das kann man
wieder wegschmeißen post silence gut jetzt können wir unser kommando sein tool bauen
weil ich muss mal kurz licht anmachen bei mir aber dazu muss ich natürlich nicht aufstehen
ich muss nur auf dem zweiten bildschirm eine home automation anmachen ins arbeitszimmer
gehen auf den decke knopf drücken und schon habe ich licht an hock also das ist die sache
wo ich bin ich sicher bin ok hostname ok jetzt müssen wir gucken welche sachen sind
gesetzt also es gibt eigentlich nur die möglichkeit dass na gut der passt das ja schon das ist
korrekt gesetzt das ist korrekt gesetzt wenn nicht setzen wir es hier wieso smartphone
wenn man es selbst machen muss naja weil ich die lichter nicht automatisch einschalten
lasse außer drüben im wohnzimmer weil ich nicht weiß ob ich zu der zeit in dem raum
bin und wenn du jetzt auf alexa oder sowas anspielst nee sowas habe ich nicht so host
silence silence silence ist eigentlich tatsächlich in der basic funktionalität alles was wir
brauchen oder jetzt kann man das aufrufen man kann man kann einen kund angeben maintenance
zum beispiel wisst ihr was auch noch cool wäre wenn man den aktuellen user einträgt
bei autor bei autor nicht post jam sondern also quasi das was man bei who am i kriegt
weil die leute die loggen sich ja normalerweise mit ihrem ssh account ein die werden dann
ruht aber vielleicht machen sie vorher maintenance licht über presence detection ja dann musst
du presence detection machen und mach mal presence detection ohne dein smartphone dann
musst du anfangen mit bewegungs meldern und irgendwelchen wärme bildern und so also das
ist ist das environment username dann machen wir das so environment username dann ist der
autor nämlich jetzt was ist ja mit meiner schelle los mit smart mit smartwatch geht
es nur wenn man wenn die bluetooth hat so alert manager silences alle die jetzt gesetzt
hallo hallo ja created by max comment maintain das ist richtig nice das ist richtig nice
sowas muss dann auf unsere kisten drauf weil jetzt kannst du wirklich sagen einfach nur
downtime now oder wie auch immer ich das ding nenne zack du hast den name drin du hast den
host drinnen es ist gescheit für 15 minuten du kannst deine wartungsarbeit machen du kannst
ein reboot machen für kernel update und dann ist wieder gut das ist genau das genau das
was man braucht ja ok für die arbeit werde ich hier die adresse zu unserem alert manager
hardcoden man könnte noch environment variable setzen aber das ist eigentlich sinnlos das
ist gut also jetzt muss man auch ein ordentliches summary schreiben ich mein summary muss die
summary überschrift wirklich so fett sein das liest auch das liest doch eh keiner wir
schreiben wir schreiben lieber rein aber eine gute überschrift sowas wie wie auf geht's
oder oder oder maintenance oder irgendwas postchamp einfach nur postchamp so downtime
will start in also eine ordentliche ausgabe müssen wir schon machen eine ordentliche ausgabe
müssen wir schon mal an sie konzert right line right mark ab leinen wir müssen das
natürlich farbig machen so downtime will start in downtime will start in so wann startet
die downtime die downtime startet now minus start ne start minus now ist das also quasi
quatsch für sie nicht javascript also quasi date time now mit mit utc und sonst was muss
ich mir noch was überlegen wie ich das mache start minus utc was gibt denn der da aus
den blödsinn oder ach so nao ist jetzt ja nao ist jetzt ja später ne ne das ist ok
dass das das das ist in ordnung tatsächlich weil die startzeit ist ja entweder nao oder
in der zukunft so und außerdem ist die ausgabe eh kacke wir holen uns noch ein anderes package
das wird schöner aus leute wir haben so viele dependencies unsinnigerweise drin aber ok warum
nicht so pass mal auf auch richtig nice das nougat package jetzt kann man nämlich sagen
humanize wenn ich es richtig geschrieben was nochmal value eget und jetzt und jetzt pass
mal auf jetzt schreibt er in ok das muss ich ein bisschen anders anders waren start
in 230 milliseconds ok da können wir jetzt sagen min min unit ist minute und max unit
ist hour so und dann ist gut was jetzt oh gott was jetzt wo ist das problem aber darf man
da kein zeilenumbruch machen drin oder wie ok das muss ich da muss ich was anderes überlegen
das muss das das ist doof das ist doof das kann ich ja auch nicht inline machen sucked
passive suck so da müssen wir irgendwie sowas sowas war begin fällt grad nichts besseres
ein start minus utc nao und wenn das wenn das wenn das kleiner wenn das kleiner null
ist dann ist es dann ist es null und ansonsten ist blöd das gefällt mir alles nicht ok wenn
also wenn begin kann man das kleiner checken null kann das time span kleiner null dann
eins ansonsten zwei ne das kann timespan nicht timespan kann man kann man timespan vergleichen
ist das kleiner kann man checken ob timespan irgendwie negativ ist oder muss ich vergleichen
kleiner timespan und ansetzt nicht start utc nao sondern dann einfach war timespan kann
ich negativ sein doch hast doch gerade eben gesehen kann negativ sein guck ein ding funktioniert
es ist minus 160 millisekunden kecke also kann das geht geht schon ich mein man könnte
natürlich sowas machen ja kleiner timespan zero ja sowas könnte ich machen wenn es kleiner
timespan zero ist dann ja das ist wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich ganz sinnvoll so wenn es kleiner
timespan zero ist dann nao und ansonsten begin äh sag mal bin ich gerade zu blöd zu schreiben
oder sowas dann für schmerzen wo wo ist das problem was klammern wo
klammern klammern um die rechten nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein das ist doch
ok das müsste doch eigentlich passen war keckel doch auch richtig ach man darf das
dann nicht ach so stimmt dass mit doppelpunkt und string format beißt sich dass du dann
sowas sagen könnt wie nachkommastelle und sowas ok ich glaube das problem hatte ich
noch nie ja verstehe ja weil du kannst sowas machen wie float irgendwie nachkommastelle
2 und solche geschichten negativ gibt es nicht ok dann mal was so nao ansonsten ist
es beginn punkt so und dann min unit minutes max unit hours so und precision 2 dann zeigt
der immer minute immer minuten und stunden an so so ist das so ist das glaube ich ganz
nice ja mit klammern wird es tatsächlich funktionieren ja irgendwie so aber das ist
eben bisschen zu lang so jetzt sollte das so funktionieren so nao ok passt alles klar
gut das passt duration duration sind hier was geben an total total minutes oder so wir
geben wir geben das in wir geben das in minuten an total minutes minutes ich glaube so ist
du machst einfach nur duration lässt ihn selber formatieren nee das will ich nicht
weil einfach nur duration ist doof dann dann lässt er minuten weg und so achso das hier
können wir aber tatsächlich machen das können wir machen das können wir machen ok so zeigt
mal her was kommt jetzt raus down time will start now das ist gut down time will start
now so und wenn ich jetzt angebe start erst um 22 uhr start erst um 22 uhr dann sagt
er down time will start in 2 stunden 14 utc alda utc shit time zones pains champ down time
will start in 39 minutes das ist doch gut das muss ich mir überlegen wie ich das wie
ich das mit zeit so ungescheit umgehe ja oder mit daytime offset achso in ja du hast recht
der in passt dann aber mit now wieder nicht ok will start in will start in now
ich weiß will start in now ist auch ein bisschen peppiger oder ja das problem ist mit alles
in local time die leute die hier was eingeben ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob das dann
in welcher in welcher zeitzone ist das denn jetzt also wenn jetzt einer duration angibt
22 uhr so guck mal mal hier return und das machen wir einfach mal nix anderes wie duration
so duration ist nicht duration lull alter start meine ich das es nicht duration so jetzt
sagt er mir das ist 10 uhr ok also die kokona schreibweise du hast recht das ist eine super
idee das hier unten reinzuschreiben hier ja also dass man quasi hier in den in davor
schreibt irgendwie so in der richtung und das now ist und hier das in weg macht ja
so gute idee so also start und jetzt wenn ich sag start utc muss das irgendwie also utc
mein time to local time to universal time so by the way leute es gibt irgendeinen trick
dass man nicht value schreiben muss ja so war das da kannst du diese null operator verwenden
dann entpackt er das nämlich automatisch da musst du kein value schreiben ich hab's
gestern mit dem realismus mod probiert ich bin dann irgendwann mal auf den server gekommen
eineinhalb stunden später ich habe insgesamt drei leute gekillt weil die genauso blöd
waren wie ich und ansonsten siehst du keine leute die auf dich ballern das muss ich mir
noch mal in ruhe angucken ok da checkt das da checkt das wenn das einer setzt ja dann
ist alles dann ist doch alles gut das einzige was ich jetzt machen muss dass das mit der
urzeit stimmt ist doch im endeffekt an der stelle wo starts ad steht muss ich sagen universal
ist das problem ach weil es jetzt in alle bill ist was ich mache mach mal ausrufezeichen
heute ist es glaube ich
ist es egal na enden macht ja kein unterschied ich muss was anders machen mit diesen mit
diesen optional types ist doof ich muss das einmal null checken und dann in irgendwas
ich will ja nicht jedes mal value da vorschreiben da kriegst du anfälle also so so passt das
doch jetzt wird das umgerechnet in die jeweilige in die utc start time weil unser blöder alert
manager auf utc läuft ich sehe ich sehe schon kommen die leute gehen dann immer auf den
server und setzen die maintenance weil es einfacher ist als utc im kopf umzurechnen
so passt doch jetzt eigentlich duration kannst du angeben start kannst du angeben reason kannst
du angeben autor kannst du angeben aber autor ist ja doch autor ja ja autor kannst du angeben
doch es gibt daytime now bringt mir ja nix ich will ja daytime now in meiner zeit und
dann will ich es umrechnen in utc die leute geben das immer in eigener zeit ein und wie
gibt man jetzt start morgen früh ein morgen früh gibst du folgendermaßen ein also mal
angenommen du willst heute nacht um 3 oder ja morgen früh um 3 also jetzt 0 uhr 3 willst
du das nächste 0 uhr 3 willst du für ja du willst für was weiß ich für 15 minuten
wartungsarbeiten machen um 0 uhr 3 oder um 3 uhr und ich um 0 uhr 3 um 3 uhr da würdest
du jetzt angeben man wird jetzt erstmal denken dass da aber das ist schiebe also ich glaube
nicht dass es funktioniert wir müssen mal gucken ich glaube nicht dass es richtige datum nimmt
was jetzt bed request mag er nicht warum nicht ich wollte eigentlich was anderes zeigen wie
man das eingeben kann 18 ne guck das kann er so nicht so was man machen kann ist du gibst
ihm was hat er denn für also weil die zeit nicht gültig ist deswegen kann er keine lörd
hinzufügen ok das ist natürlich sinnvoll was du machen kannst ist du kannst angeben anstatt
0 uhr 3 kannst du angeben 19.07.2022 0 uhr 3 das funktioniert muss ich mit slash das angeben
oh nee das ist kokona datums format das muss ich umstellen also niemand niemand gibt bei
uns kokona kokona datum an das muss ich umstellen also am datum ist 07.18.2022
nee wo ist das problem
mach mehrere endparameter mal gucken warte startet jetzt wenigstens an der richtigen zeit
du kannst ihm sagen 17 da aber das muss ich umdrehen alda meine güte dass das muss das
muss eu eu datums format sein habt ihr den use case überhaupt mit datum
haben wir nicht doch aber dann setzt es niemand über den server das setzt jeder über das
maintenance gui das macht keiner vom server aus das habe ich nur eigentlich nur gemacht
weil jemand im chat gefragt hat wie würdest du das setzen mach ein time only stimmt du
hast recht keine schlechte idee weil das gibt es ja seit der letzten framework version das
ist ja noch nicht neu im only das ist eine gute idee ein only das gibt es erst seit einem
jahr oder so das ist noch fast schon bleeding edge ich probiere das mal kurz aus wie er
das konvertiert
jetzt wo ist das problem jetzt also probieren wir mal time only kackel und jetzt was sagt
er mir wenn ich nichts angebe requires a value ok requires a value blub blub blub dann sagt
er mir es muss ein time only sein und time only was ist denn wenn ich als 24 angebe oder
so wie muss man ein time only angeben irgendwie zwölf zwölf oder so ok das pm am monka man
das muss to string culture info wo gibt man das jetzt ein to culture info keine ahnung
mal stimmt ich habe den human humanizer der kann das ja 7 hours ago ja wunderbar 12 uhr
war 7 hours ago
wobei das nicht nicht nicht so geil ist ach hier kann man culture info machen
es geht aber in dort net selbst auch man konnte to string format provider wie ging das culture
info genau
be das weiß ich aus dem kopf nicht wie das funktioniert
ah ja doch hier c sharp culture info germany zeitzone sind richtig pain
ach kann man die idee schreiben noch besser so gucken wir mal ob das ob das die das deutsche
datumsformat ist gehen wir ein 23 uhr 41 ah das sieht gut aus weil wenn ich das hier weglassen
würde dann kommt dann so ein komischer so ein komischer müll raus wie 11 uhr 41 pm
und so was wer will wer will denn so was haben ok ich weiß ich weiß ich weiß wer es
haben will hell yeah wir messen auch unsere gewichte bei amazon in ounces ja du hast recht
wir sollten die culture info vom ganzen programm setzen
kann man das hier wie setzt man das ist tatsächlich wie setzt man culture info komplett glaube
man mit environment variablen gehts aber das kann ja nicht sollte ja nicht so sein culture
info vielleicht ja ok ja ja so das müsste eigentlich reichen
ja funktioniert funktioniert dann hätte ich auch selbst drauf kommen können ok jetzt
jetzt macht er das nämlich alles schön auf deutsch weil das sonst affig ok jetzt müssen
wir noch löschen einbauen list list nein wir bauen list ein ja wir machen das hier
tatsächlich zu einem time only so jetzt brauchen wir so was wie l list das ist ein bool wenn
ich optional mache dann wobei ist ist das optional wenn ich es wenn ich es weglasse
bei einem bool du hast du racen anscheinend starrt oh i'm spam ja geil jetzt weiß ich
nicht wie der kram hier funktioniert muss es wahrscheinlich eher als daytime machen
ich ich will erst mal dass es durchläuft aber hier noch ok also lists ist es pflicht
dass ich list angebe wenn ich es nicht optional mache nein ist es nicht sehr schön also wenn
list wir können das ganz wir können das ganz einfach abfackeln also wenn lists gesetzt
ist dann will ich nichts machen von diesem anderen krempe sondern mein api aufruf machen
den da den ich mir irgendwo gespeichert habe und einfach nur ausgeben was gesetzt ist für
diesen host und dann schön schön formatiert ausgeben
ach warum mache ich da immer console rightline drumherum dafür habe ich mir doch dieses
extension ding gebaut jetzt ist nicht gesetzt jetzt sage ich hier einfach mal minus minus
list oder minus l und dann gibt da nur die silences aus die gesetzt sind dafür das ist
schon mal ziemlich pock und das formatieren wir jetzt schön als tabelle spektrum console
table wir machen ja ziemlich viel schnick schnack für optik aber mein warum nicht da
hat man was new table ja das wollen wir haben übrigens wir werden wir werden wahrscheinlich
da noch eigene funktionen draus machen für list und clear und so weil warum sollte das
alles in einem stehen also table so add column add column so was wollen wir dann haben was
was wollen wir hier von auszeigen ja eigentlich ach so ha da sind jetzt auch die expired drinne
die expired müssen wir rausfiltern das wollen wir nicht das wollen wir nicht haben id interessiert
kein mensch eigentlich eigentlich interessiert doch eigentlich ja nur start und ende oder
ansonsten ist es doch ziemlich egal created und comment noch ok ok also start duration
detected by unit tests alles klar comment aber guter witz gewesen ok add row wie sieht
das jetzt aus wenn ich das jetzt ausführe factories alleine reicht nicht das müssen
factory factory adapter abstract repository pattern sein das muss also wenn wenn deine
klasse nicht mindestens bis in seile bis in seile 250 der namen hat dann ist irgendwas
falsch guckt euch mal guten guten java code auf github an so muss das sein ok and roll
richtiger page ja ok for each sei es könnten ja mehrere gesetzt sein silence silence in
silences wollen wir jetzt eine row adden eine row end die enthält ist das die row nee warte
mal nee das muss einfach nur und je nachdem wie ok also silence als erstes ist start dann
ist silence heißt nicht duration end das muss ich übrigens selbst ausrechnen stelle
habe ich gerade festgestellt dann wollen wir ausgeben silence created by und dann mal
ausgeben silence comment so das funst wahrscheinlich nicht weil ich hier noch to string machen
muss und hier noch so string machen muss nee so string machen muss und jetzt funktioniert
was was das achso nee wait a minute das stört sich da dran moment warum stört er sich da
dran der müsste doch anhand des flows erkennen dass ihn das mal über
also wenn ich ok ok also wenn ich das jetzt in den else haue dann geht's wahrscheinlich
nicht oder ok das ist das ist pains champ ja oder nur im blog deswegen muss das allein
schon mal eine andere funktion rein guck dir mal ey leute das sieht doch richtig schick
aus oder list guck mal da sieht das nicht progas hübsch aus
das ist das ist tatsächlich richtig na ja die duration ist falsch das muss ich noch
ausrechnen ja also ich brauche ich brauche dann quasi hier so was wie war na start start
ist ok eine güde jetzt ist das ding aber ganz schön ganz schön pingelig so jetzt muss
ich nämlich noch ausrechnen duration an die duration gibt schon ein weiterer grund warum
ich das warum ich das vielleicht in in extra funktion hauen sollte duration gleich start
silence end minus start das ist die duration humaniese und das ganze jetzt please wieder
da unten in dieser in dieser schreibweise kann ich euch da kann ich euch an der stelle
trotzdem was zeigen das gefällt mir das ist schick das startet 18 18.07.2020 18.52 es dauert
14 minuten wahrscheinlich weil sich die sekunden doof überschnitten haben und das blöderweise
abrundet ja vielleicht ist auch tatsächlich du hast
recht der start ist eigentlich doch ja chat ist ist richtig ihr habt recht die duration
interessiert doch eigentlich gar kein an der stelle es interessiert tatsächlich wann
das endet ja nein nein nein nicht die versagen es interessiert doch wirklich wann das endet
deswegen sollte ich nicht duration nennen sondern einfach end ja das ist tatsächlich
in dem fall duration left chat deswegen deswegen mache ich das hier im stream time left das
ist nämlich auch noch ganz interessant ja und wir haben wir haben ja eh platz wir haben
ihr platz das kann ich aber kurz rückgängig machen ich brauche den kram nämlich noch
mal
ich brauche den kram so time left so wunderbar und jetzt machen wir nämlich
hier noch das da rein chat consulting genau so und jetzt kann ich euch doch noch was zeigen
weil das sieht jetzt mega beschissen aus kann kein mensch lesen was ich da geschrieben habe
aber schauen wir mal ja nice moment time left passt aber nicht das ist doch schon abgelaufen
keckel alter das moment so funktioniert das nicht mit time left das muss ich zu nahe machen
ich muss ich muss gucken ob das ne ne das das ist auf jeden fall ne ne ne das ist bei
mir ist nix ut oder ist das ut keine ahnung ich muss vor allem ich muss vor allem in utc
muss ich das machen ja ich hasse zeitzonen mann so ein pains champ alter ein kurz klima
lage anmachen ok also was sie was ich haben will ist datetime now so datetime now utc
silence end minus utc now time left
schaue ob das irgendwie sinn ergibt das sollte jetzt ja im irgendeinen minus sein ja ergibt
keinen sinn ich weiß also wenn kleiner null dann null und ansonsten die zeit ok dann dann
ja das ergibt sinn ok dann setzen wir mal was also set moment sollte nicht da eigentlich
noch mehr drin stehen warte mal wo ist der alert manager also moment warum kommt da nur
eine silence warum kommt da bei einem list nicht mehr oder nur die sind das nur die active
silences perl mensch nö das sind alle aber gestern aber ne filter ist falsch ah ja der
filter der der filter ist falsch der filter ist falsch noch ein weiterer grund warum
ich das mal alles in ordentlich funktionen packen muss weil ansonsten blickst du hier
ja gar nicht mehr durch wo hier irgendwas passiert der filter ist falsch tatsächlich
der filter ist fail ich kann über tippen run oh ich sehe es wird spät ja passt doch
ok so und time left soll nicht zu string sondern humanisen one minute one minute 23 hours two
hours five hours one hour ja und das was negativ ist wollen wir nicht oder bei time left oh
jetzt wird es aber ja oder bei time left oder bei start ja genau negative negative
werte brauchen noch time left trill time left kleiner times spend zero expired und ansonsten
so
das ist schon mal besser oder was zwei sekunden time left leute monka es und jetzt expired
pass seconds left monka time aber es funktioniert erzählt runter ja wir sollten das wir sollten
es wirklich sortieren nach end nach end time also sort nee oder bei silences ends at easy
oder bei descending ja so ist das doch schick oder wobei ganz ehrlich die expired die würde
ich sogar rausschmeißen die die expired könnte man könnte man rausschmeißen colors ach so
ja stimmt wir haben auch den fall ist noch nicht gestartet ja da muss man noch ein bisschen
muss man sich auch ein bisschen was überlegen was ist mit denen die noch nicht gestartet
sind warte mal ich glaube die katze ist an der tür keine keine chico zu sehen hat sich
gerade so angehört als wäre die katze an der tür
theoretisch ganz ehrlich es expired braucht doch kein mensch wir zeigen einfach aktive
maintenances an und abkommen oder expired juck doch nicht also ja ends at is größer
als day time now so schon mal besser kriegt man nur die angezeigt die so die sind ja alle
noch nicht gestartet moment das ist jetzt wieder utc alle ich krieg anfälle ach nee
es endet es endet nicht ein tag später ja ja das ist naja gut das geht so schnell an
der stelle das glaube ich ok so eine sache eine sache machen wir noch wer also wer ends
also sprich wo endet größer ist als als heute also quasi alle sachen die schon als
jetzt das ist dann schon expired und dann sagen wir jetzt wer es starts at nee warte
mal was will was will ich jetzt überhaupt überprüfen ich stehe nach drei stunden bisschen
auf dem schlauch nee beim api call kann man das leider nicht
gescheit rausfiltern das ist ziemlicher müll doch doch an dem status steht das dran du
hast recht wir könnten wir könnten gucken doch doch du hast recht wir könnten gucken
status status state warum auch immer expired ungleich expired und jetzt müssten wir es
eigentlich auch gleiches ergebnis kriegen japp poggers was steht denn da eigentlich
dran wenn wenn das erst noch anfängt expired expired expired pending steht da dran pending
pending ist wenn die erst noch anfängt oder oder was ist pending active ist wenn sie gerade
läuft pending ist quasi wenn die wenn die irgendwann noch kommt oder ja wahrscheinlich
pending ist geplant ja so und jetzt gucken wir noch ob die startzeit größer ist wie
date time now utc utc utc weil dann haben wir jetzt nur die
moment umgedreht da soll größer start sein dann haben wir nur die aktiven was eine ist
aktuell ja gut wobei wollen wir das überhaupt nie abkommen abkommen wollen wir auch haben
aber man auch sehen aber da müsste ich bei abkommen müsste ich time left time left ergibt
ja wenig sinn ja da da überlege ich mir noch was ich gehe jetzt erstmal penne leute
da machen wir noch weiter an an sich die kern funktionalität ist mega simpel aber ich benutze
was halt immer gerne um was dabei zu lernen und um unsinnige dinge einzubauen ja niemand
braucht die listfunktion schon gar nicht schön formatiert in der tabelle und den ganzen
anderen krempel aber immerhin weil man lernt halt wirklich was dabei was hältst du von
lp zertifikaten als fisi azubi kann man machen wenn du es bezahlt kriegst von der firma warum
nicht ansonsten ich glaube ich kenne niemand der lp hat radiosignale hatten lp das einzige
zertifikat was ich irgendwann mal hatte war ein cc na verurzeiten was auch kein keine
sau gejuckt hat wirklich nie hat mich da irgendjemand das hat es keine interessiert also wenn es
ein arbeitgeber bezahlt ja warum nicht ich denke mal wenn du wenn du wirklich ahnung
verliehen uns hast ist der erste lp auch nicht so schwer wobei das letzte mal als ich mir
lp testfragen angeguckt habe da waren schon ein paar trickreiche sachen dabei die wollten
zum beispiel auch irgendwelche grub settings wissen wo ich sagen musste alter keine ahnung
aus dem kopf wobei ich halt immer also ich persönlich finde es ja bei zertifikaten ehrlich
gesagt fraglich die fragen sachen ab die du innerhalb von zwei sekunden selbst gegoogelt
hast oftmals ja viele zertifikate und gerade multiple choice zertifikate die fragen quasi
nicht ab hat der typ ahnung prinzipiell von der thematik und kann er schnell probleme
lösen nee die fragen ab hast du irgendwelche sysco begriffe auswendig gelernt oder irgendwelche
anderen sachen auswendig gelernt das ist aber realistisch betrachtet nix was dir in der
täglichen arbeit hilft weil in der täglichen arbeit musst du wissen was du da was du machen
willst wie das heißt und dann kannst du die settings auch mal suchen cc na quatsch der
cc na ist das unsinnigste was es also dass die niedrigste sysco zertifizierung die jeder
daher gelaufene feldwald und wiesen admin irgendwann mal gemacht habt also du spielst
garantiert nicht in einer anderen gehaltsliga nur weil du cc na hast chat wie seht ihr das
könnt ihr sagen max stimmt nicht aber so zumindest meiner meinung nach bei bei anderen
sysco zertifizierung sieht das anders aus ja wenn du wenn du das ist das aller einstägigste
einstiegigen wenn du wenn du bei wenn du allerdings jetzt irgendwie die internet engineer oder
sysco zertifizierung ich kann mir die namen nicht werken ja also wenn du diesen internet
professionell oder certified internet engineer oder sonst was gemacht hast dann sieht das
schon wieder anders aus cc na ist eine einsteiger sysco zertifizierung ja also wenn du da die
die fetten sysco zertifizierung hast die aber wirklich nicht einfach sind habe ich mir sagen
lassen ich habe selbst keine probiert bisher dann das bringt natürlich schon was ja da
stehen die leute gerade im netzwerkbereich schon schon drauf was hältst du vom was ceh
kenne ich nicht was z zertifizierung was ist das ach das ach das wusste nicht dass man
das so abkürzt kann ich aber aus dem stich greife auch nichts zu sagen jetzt war ich wie
wäre es wenn du gleich sempa video haustest haben wir das haben wir die ein der letzten
mal schon gehorst ich guck mal ich hauste ich hauste ich hauste irgendjemand anderes
heute hauste wenn hauste ich denn keine ahnung ich muss mal kurz reloaden wenn ich haust kann
also ich kann meine twitch sidebar nicht aufklappen auf meinem zweiten monitor es ist grad verbackt
da gibt es wirklich warte minute macht er echt c++ das glaube ich das ist debate das
ist jibay chat oder c++ sempa video ist aber jung geworden ach das ist werbung ja ja ja
auf ach gleich der macht überhaupt kein c++ stream jibay tut mir nicht der macht c++
ok c++ was ist das für eine ide ist das eclipse ach ne das ist c++ der c++ bilder so was gibts
noch den hatten wir auch in der berufsschule mal moin bananen flüsterer der stream ist
vorbei ich gehe jetzt auf bis leider etwas zu spät aber hier aus ich kann meine sidebar
nicht richtig angucken ich hauste jetzt gar kein leute ich gehe jetzt einfach pennen
bis morgen machts gut cu